[Music]
okay go right ahead representative
pearson as chairman of the house health
human services and elderly affairs
committee
a state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covet 19
pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
some committee members are participating
in this
meeting from the legislative office
building
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the house health human
services and elderly affairs committee
it may be followed by an executive
session please note that there are no
physical locations for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access
contemporaneously to listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa
91 a
anyone who has difficulty accessing the
or else email hcs at
leg dot
state dot
nh dot u s
in the event the public as a whole is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that is on
the meeting assisting us today including
christina dyer
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call votes
we will start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
and when each member states his or her
presence please also state whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting
this is required under the right to know
law
would the clerk please call
representative marsh
i'm president and i'm in my home office
in brookfield and i'm currently in law
representative mcmahon can you put your
does it work now okay
uh
no
i'll come back to you okay
come on are you okay here it goes there
we go thank you
um yeah i'm still here
okay
i'm not present in my office in windham
and i'm alone
okay thank you representative nelson
[Music]
representative acton
uh good morning i am here and i'm in my
uh kitchen with my nine-year-old
daughter on school vacation running
oh there you are you are in the house
okay um
representative cushman
president
thank you representative folsom home and
will about to be alone
uh representative kelsey
i'm here at my house in bedford and i'm
alone otherwise i have my two dogs
though
representative king
and here at the lop
thank you
representative kobal
i am here in my home office in wilton
and i am alone in this room but there
are other people in the house
representative weber
she told me that she has to testify on a
few things but we will be joining us
eventually thank you representative
mccain
i'm i'm here in concord down the street
and i'm alone in the office
representative
i am uh here in my home study in freedom
and my wife is in some other part of the
house for a while then she's going to be
going to work
representative soloway
[Music]
good morning representative folsom at
the moment i am at home in my office
alone however i will be mobile through
the day i expect to be in continuing
contact via audio except for a brief
interlude where i will not be available
thank you
representative cannon
i'm here in my home in the summer sports
new hampshire alone thank you
representative
i'm here in nashua in the living room
alone uh
family members in the house elsewhere
representative shapiro
president i am in my home office in
keene with some my wife is in the house
representative woods
uh present i'm in bow in my home i'm in
my study by myself but my wife is
elsewhere in the house
representative merchant
here i'm in claremont in my home office
and i'm alone
representative pearson
[Music]
i am present and i am with some
colleagues in the lobby
representative peterson on uh
representative nelson checking in i'm at
my home in brookfield
okay thank you
now before we start the first hearing
it's one of those dilemmas of life as we
know it that sometimes is a clash
between two
very enjoyable things that are going on
simultaneously
the question is how do we solve this
well i like to look for third
options therefore we will be adjourning
this afternoon no later than 3 15
because i don't want to have attendance
at this committee clash with attendance
of some of you at your party caucus why
should you be deprived of one fun thing
for another
and thank you president
for the heads up on that one thank you
mr chair
can we
can we pull this back a little
opening the hearing on
house bill
89 qualifying adding qualifying medical
conditions to the therapeutic use of the
cannabis law and i will call on
representative vail who is the prime
sponsor
good morning can you hear me
yes we can thank you
thank you
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee
i am here before you to ask you to
support house bill 89 an act that adds
moderate to severe insomnia to the
qualifying conditions for the state of
new hampshire's therapeutic cannabis
program
this bill was filed last year but never
made it to the senate due to the state
of emergency i believe it was tabled new
hampshire's system to provide cannabis
for medical use was signed into law in
2013. the intent of the cannabis
therapeutic cannabis program is to help
people with chronic and terminal and
debilitating illnesses
this system of alternative care is one
of the strictest programs in the nation
with its enclosed self-funded and
self-sourcing dispensaries also known as
alternative treatment centers
that enclosed provide safety consistency
and product integrity
the program has successfully allowed
thousands of new hampshire residents to
gain control of their symptoms and
chronic illnesses and to provide comfort
for those who are unable to eat and in
terminal illness
as a result of treatment of severe
symptoms that bring one into the program
tcp patients consistently report they
experience improvement in sleep which in
turn allows homeostasis in the body
have receptors for the elements of
cannabis and there is a vast
endocannabinoid system that is
responsible for regulating bodily
systems
how does it help so many different and
distinct symptoms
i'll allow the experts to take that
explanation further
modern
moderate to severe insomnia is related
to mental illness anxiety agitation
depression and increased prevalence of
nightmares it causes moderate to severe
physical stress on every system in the
body and exacerbates chronic illness the
presence of insomnia is broad and
widespread occurring in 10 to 30 percent
of the population according to the
national institute of health
i believe that right now we can safely
assume there are more cases of moderate
to severe insomnia
than ever due to the stress of the
pandemic the state of the emergency and
the profound effect of massive loss of
life
loss of income and increased uncertainty
about what it's what is ahead
insomnia is very difficult to treat
medicinally due to the manners in which
pharmaceutical compounds impact the rest
of the body
sleep medicine can be habit-forming and
cause side effects such as tolerance and
excessive dryness caused by
over-the-counter sleep aids
prescription sleep aids can also cause
addiction sleep walking sleep driving
and patients are often
cautioned
that when they're treating their
insomnia they must not drive the next
day
these medications
and our and older compounds are almost
unilaterally addictive
cannabis comes in many forms that have
no lingering sedative effects and when
cbd the cannabinoid
is isolated from
from thc
there is no psychoactive component in
the product there are many choices for
consuming the product and many
combinations of compounds to explore to
getting better sleep a patient of the
tcp can find the best product by working
with the dispensary staff to find what
works best for them
those who consider nightmares to be an
essential part of their problem have
been able to find appropriate doses of
speak of thc which also combats
additional symptoms of ptsd
those who can fall asleep earlier stay
sleep longer and decrease in waking up
early achieve a better quality of life
in summary new hampshire we have in new
hampshire
we have a closed system to offer
alternative treatment where all products
are controlled tested measured dosed and
packed into tamper-proof containers
these compounds are available in many
forms in order to address an
individual's experience and how they
want to be able to ingest their medicine
these
the taming of the insomnia
will really limit the
the incidence of chronic illness and the
loss of quality of life that that
happens once people get very sick from
being unable to sleep
the level of purity and integrity cannot
be found in
in the um in the natural environment
where people are forced to treat system
symptoms with of of insomnia with
products of unknown origin that bear the
label of a known component
cbd
this risk is taken routinely by new
hampshire people because they want to
sleep
treating moderate to severe insomnia
before it gets that far and is key here
thank you for listening to my comments
in support of the bill
i do want to point out that there is a
fiscal note included in the bill that
shows an interminable indeterminable
increase in revenue due to increasing
applications to the therapeutic cannabis
program
with that i will take any questions but
there will be expert testimony this
morning and technical questions that may
be better answered by others who came to
speak
i do want to mention about the last
year's bill that it was approved by the
um the municipal board and um that bill
unfortunately
died when it was tabled in the senate
probably due to the coveted crisis
um so with that thank you mr chair and
to the committee please support this
bill as it is today with the motion of
ought to pass and please consider
anything that's to come forth
as i wrap up my presentation thank you
thank you representative vale and uh
since uh representative kenner from our
own committee uh serves on the board
and is probably the one of the ones
you're referring to who will bring
additional expert information i'm going
to call on him next and then give the
committee a chance to question either
you or representative knurk
or both
so representative conor you're up next
there we are
okay
uh yes for the record i'm jerry kanerk
representing carroll county district
three and um
i also serve as the chair of the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board
the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board also known as tcmob is
composed of the chief medical officer of
dhhs a qualifying patient representative
a clinical representative from an atc
and 10 medical providers from various
fields we are charged with the task of
advising the therapeutic cannabis
program on medical issues including
qualifying conditions
as representative fail already noted
last year
this bill came forward it was part of hb
and this the tcmob devoted a great deal
of time to considering that condition
and some other conditions that were part
of that bill and yes it got to the house
and uh then just died to cover death
now the process of evaluating this
condition included a public hearing
review of the literature regarding
therapeutic cannabis use and insomnia
and a thorough discussion
tcmob was very diligent using their
personal experience exhaustive
literature reviews and testimonials from
patients to make their recommendation
for those of you who are new to the
therapeutic cannabis program are new to
this committee
because we cover their bills the bills
that have to do with them qualifying
conditions are in rsa 126x
they're the conditions for which a
patient may be qualified to be certified
to use therapeutic cannabis in new
hampshire and the qualifying conditions
include three standalone conditions or
the combination of a qualifying
diagnosis
with an associated qualifying symptom
uh tcmob voted nine to one to recommend
the addition of moderate to severe
insomnia as a qualifying symptom
uh and i'm just gonna give you a very
brief uh
information i did email to everybody our
full report that we
processed in the end of 2019 because
this had been a retained bill from 19
and um that goes into a lot more detail
i'm just going to give the high points
here because that's a big
report
but the majority of studies suggest that
use of thc and thc derivatives alone or
in combination with cbd may improve
self-reported sleep quality
may decrease sleep disturbances and
decrease sleep onset latency that's the
amount of time it takes you while you
sit and toss and turn and count sheep
while you're trying to go to sleep the
studies are limited in reaching
conclusions but overall point to more
beneficial effects than deleterious
now uh representative already pointed
out some very important issues and that
is that there are current
pharmacological treatments for insomnia
or primary sleep disorders are not great
they're limited by side effects uh they
cause there's there's addiction
liability the benefits of some of these
prescription sleep medications are
really sometimes rather minimal they're
approved by the fda but one of them for
example only allows you to fall asleep
as an average six minutes earlier and
only adds a total of 16 minutes of total
sleep on average that's not a lot of
gain and these minimal improvements
often come with increased risk the next
day of
drowsiness confusion increased traffic
accidents hallucinations and sleep
paralysis
now that isn't to imply that the
cannabinoids are perfectly risk freaks
they are not
they are also associated with adverse
effects such as dizziness cognitive
impairment also increased risk of motor
vehicle accidents psychosis dependence
depression and anxiety so they also do
need to be used with caution just
because they're natural doesn't mean
they're risk-free
the point is too that some of the
medications current regular
pharmacologic
medications we have to treat insomnia
can affect the sleep architecture that's
your as you cycle through the various
stages and one study demonstrated that
cannabinoid preparations may have fewer
effects on sleep architecture than the
traditional medications
the particular preparation and dosing of
cannabinoids may be an important factor
and more research is actually needed
into that
bottom line they'll always remember that
improving sleep habits and behavioral
therapy should be the first line
treatments and that works for almost
everybody but tcmob does feel that
therapeutic cannabis can be a reasonable
alternative when those do not suffice
i'm going to pivot for a moment though
too because you may have wondered how
come i sent off this amendment to this
bill it's not because i thought this
bill had a problem
it is because
we at ccmub has also
wanted to approve adding autism spectrum
disorder as a stand-alone condition
and i've sent you that amendment and
i've gotten the permission of the
sponsor of this bill to con for us to
consider that
this is a result of work that tcmob did
last year evaluating sb 700 that aimed
to add asd as a qual
asd autism spectrum disorder as a
qualifying condition but it also died a
cove of death and
we were rather surprised when we found
out that senator reagan did not file it
again and the board agreed it would be
reasonable for us to offer it as an
amendment to hb 89 and also 605 which we
hear later
we had agreed on voted nine to zero to
add asd as a standalone qualifying
condition
again the process was lengthy with the
public hearing review the literature and
a thorough discussion there are studies
underway looking specifically at the use
of therapeutic cannabis and asd but
strong evidence is lacking as there is
for almost everything in therapeutic
cannabis and actually for those of you
who aren't aware of it sometimes strong
evidence is lacking in some of our
standard pharmacological interventions
as well the testimony to hearing and
written testimony provided compelling
anecdotal evidence for the usefulness in
treating agitation seen in individuals
with asd
and the desperation of parents
and caregivers with such behavior
now
as one person said that was quite
eloquent it is one thing when you have a
nine-year-old
with autism having a little hissy fit on
the floor in the in the grocery store
it's another thing when they're 25.
so that can be a really important thing
and this particular person found that a
very minimal five milligrams of thc a
day
really calmed him down he was able to
function and even became i think if i
remember right mildly verbal which he
had not been not a miracle drug that's
not the issue but it really worked well
for him and other meds didn't work well
we did have some patients who had a
negative outcome so it does require some
close monitoring
we do know particularly that there are
deleterious effects of cannabis on the
developing brain and that makes the use
of therapeutic cannabis in young
patients really concerning
so given those considerations
we recommended the addition of autism
spectrum disorder as a standalone for
those over 21 but with rather severe uh
specific safeguards to those under 21.
we added that
we voted to add the requirement of an
evaluation of a provider or child or
adolescent psychiatry or pediatric
neurology who confirms that asd has not
responded to previously prescribed
medications or that other treatment
options produced serious side effects
and they support certification for the
use of the therapeutic cannabis so as
chair of the board and their leg
legislative liaison and with the
concurrence of dhh
staff i brought forth this amendment now
there's one slight substantive
difference over what we actually voted
on
when we processed this later we realized
we could add developmental pediatricians
as a provider specialist who can provide
the required consultation for those
under 21 and we did that to improve
provider access given the paucity of the
other two types of providers in our
state so all three of those are people
who can serve as that second
opinion if you will that this indeed is
reasonable so in summary
the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board has strongly agreed and
recommended
the underlying portion of this bill
which is very moderate to severe
insomnia it would like us to also
consider adding autism spectrum disorder
as an amendment
that's all i have thank you
before we go any further
my cataract free eyes seem to detect
representative snow on the screen are
you with us in the meeting
i am here am i unmuted
yes well done thank you this is
representative snow i'm i'm in my
apartment in manchester and my wife is
present elsewhere in the apartment thank
representative webber only for the
purpose of introducing yourself at this
point thank you mr chairman and i am
representative lucy weber i am at my
home in concord
i have a friend staying who may be in
and out but she's not presently in the
room and is not going to spend any great
deal of time in the room with me
thank you representative i have a
clarification question for
representative canark actually i have
two
um i just sent up to house committee
services because i do not have a copy of
0437h
which is probably because i lost it but
they're going to get me a new one but
they say that they do not have a fiscal
note upstairs and i believe you said
is there one
he's not
check with representative vail yes there
is a fiscal note on the bill
hb 89 it's the
last page
okay they said upstairs they didn't see
it but if everybody else has it i'll
peek over somebody's shoulder and the
second clarifying question is i believe
you said that there would be added a
developmental pediatrician
is that to be added
in the amendment or a new amendment or
how
no that is already in the new one i was
just noting that the actual official
board in the minutes of tcmob
did not report out the developmental
pediatrician um because we realized that
after we'd had the vote we did not have
time to go back we we had to get this
turned around out to the senate under a
deadline and we didn't meet for another
month so uh we just took the liberty of
adding that because it was the same type
of person it is already in the amendment
that i have
submitted
so the amendment is clean as it stands
thank you very much um
do i i do not see any questions from the
committee for either representatives
mail or canary am i missing a hand
somewhere
i do see one in the upper left hand
corner
yup that's the hand and the chair
recognizes that hand and i'm going to
yes thank you mr chairman um
i have a question
probably related to my ignorance about
the
original
bill and program for therapeutic
cannabis
as you said in your testimony
representative kenner
there's mention of stand-alone
conditions or qualifying diagnosis
diagnoses
or qualifying symptoms
for example
let's use
insomnia
which which category is that in is it a
is it a standalone condition is it a
qualifying symptom
um
what if it's the only symptom without a
qualifying condition can you explain how
that works yes matt thank you very much
it is
what this bill does is put it in as one
of the qualifying symptoms
and um
the difficulty here is that we as a
board had some concerns about it just
being used willy-nilly for the primary
problem of poor sleep because again it
is probably better that you would use
cognitive
behavioral therapy and other um
types of maneuvers to try to treat
insomnia first but there is a very
interesting catch-all
uh that exists i i don't have it the
statute opened in front of me right now
but there is a phraseology in the
conditions which says or some other
condition which results in the following
symptom it really is kind of a loophole
that allows somebody to
sort of write for a purest symptom i can
pull that up but it'll take me just a
but um
does that answer your question
reasonably well it's this bill adds it
as a symptom and we thought probably not
to have it as a standalone
um yes it it clarifies that it's um not
really that clear and so there's a
there's discretion in terms of the
person who is
going to um make the decision about it
being a qualifying condition
uh yes and i've finally got it up
the phraseology is
after the laundry list of qualifying
diagnoses the last phrases or one or
more injuries or conditions
that has resulted in one or more
qualifying symptoms under sub-paragraph
two
it's kind of a large loophole it kind of
means that you really don't probably
have to have any of those conditions so
you could uh a person could have just
for example
um
anxiety not anxiety but some other kind
of mental health problem that gives them
insomnia and the practitioner may go
yeah i think that's a reasonable option
so there are there are some interesting
loopholes in the way that law is written
thank you
anyone else on the
committee with a question
i don't see a hand up and i don't have a
text from my wingman indicating so
representatives valentink for your
testimony
the chair calls heather stockwell a
lobbyist with rights in democracy new
hampshire she is in support and she says
hi i don't know if i'll use up a full
three minutes um just wanted to try to
be realistic
today i appreciate every everyone that's
spoken and asked questions about this
bill
my husband is someone who provided
testimony
on the last go round of this bill and
suffers
from autistic spectrum disorder
because in the last year i um i
personally have suffered from insomnia
and um
uh did try try some uh thc uh to remedy
that and i
woke up feeling more refreshed than i
had been um in a very long time
because i hadn't woken up
over and over again throughout the night
so
so there's just a little personal
attachment but i also really feel that
this is um this is a pretty small uh
step in
uh cannabis legalization as someone
mentioned earlier there are safety uh
measures taken for developing the
products that are in these stores and my
feeling is that with the continued
adding of conditions
that there will be more and more options
so for instance someone that prefers
less thc or more cbd or none at all
there will be more and more options
uh to find the right thing that works
for you or you between you and your
doctor
um
i do feel that one of the reasons i'm
here today too is just for personal
rights
i think this is uh this is something
that has been used as
in medicinal ways for
centuries actually
certainly through my lifetime
and that these people have been punished
throughout my lifetime and we've seen
them be oppressed because
of
the use of these drugs instead of
uh so-called prescription drugs which
someone also here testified today that
those prescription drugs often have uh
side effects
uh that aren't beneficial the next day
and in even can
cause a person not to be able to drive
or continue working or
or whatever they need to do
so i'm also coming at this from a
recovery perspective uh in my line of
work uh the overdose crisis is a really
big piece of what i'm working on and
the stories that i've heard from folks
in recovery is that
this is also uh in the right amounts and
the right dosages uh a really beneficial
thing for them so i can i would
encourage you to continue this uh
research and and support this bill
for the many people who who are
suffering currently and who have
suffered in the past
thanks so much i will take questions if
any i see no questions uh thank you for
your testimony
the chair now recognizes the lap excuse
me the last person who signed up to
speak uh at least by 8 30 this morning
david cyrek and he is representing
himself as a member of the public and he
i'm having difficulty finding him in the
there's a number of phone numbers only
when you asked it looked like uh the
phone number raised a hand so maybe we
can give that a shot
okay let's see here
hello this is dr david sarrick how are
you
yes dr cyrus we hear you well thank you
so much
can you hear me okay
okay just so you know my name is dr
david sarick i'm medical director for
sanctuary tc uh we operate medical
cannabis dispensaries in both plymouth
and conway thank you for the opportunity
to speak here
sanctuary atc is
we are in strong support of house bill
as medical director over the last five
years
i have consulted with say thousands of
patients and have heard
um directly from them or from our staff
that patients often report
a this in terms of insomnia report a
more solid and restful night's sleep
when they medicate at night with
cannabis
particularly an indica strain which
tends to be more sedating and conducive
to sleep
and just as cannabis has helped
thousands of our patients with chronic
pain issues i'd say just as many report
to us
on the positive sleep benefits that
therapeutic cannabis gives them
and although you know what i'm talking
about may be anecdotal evidence
um these patients reporting to us are
coming back to us i mean obviously
they're not lying this really helps them
with sleep at night
many patients report that instead of
getting
two to three hours of sleep per night
many are sleeping now
six to eight hours of of sleep tonight
and many of them now are much more
functional the next day um which helps
them with their with their work and also
with their family issues
um and as mentioned before
um i guess i believe
representative vale mentioned the
endocannabinoid system which is the
scientific basis of how cannabis works
in our body
what cannabis does is help suppress rem
sleep
rapid eye movement sleep which is when
we dream but instead it puts us into a
more deep level sleep which actually is
more therapeutic and lets the body heal
okay so that's kind of the science of
how the
the plant works in our body in terms of
helping patients sleep better in terms
of the endocannabinoid system our own
internal uh system that's um was
genetically inbred in us so let's go
back and um
discuss quickly a 2020 study
uh in the
bmj the british medical journal
which was titled medical cannabis and
insomnia in older adults with chronic
pain
they concluded that medical cannabis use
may have an overall positive effect on
maintaining sleep throughout the night
in chronic pain patients
so you know based upon our experience
with patients at sanctuary atc
and um several studies that have shown
that indeed cannabis can help with
insomnia um we are in strong support of
it i didn't really plan on discussing
autism spectrum disorder but i do know
that a lot of our patients with asd
do benefit from cannabis um so we are
also in support of it in turn in terms
of the autism spectrum disorder as well
thank you for listening to me
thank you dr uh cyrux are there any
questions from the committee for the
doctor
yes my
quick who is this
nelson
representative nelson you may ask a
question
yes uh has autism speaks the
i i have not done my research on that
i'm not sure if representative kirk can
maybe comment on that because he's done
more of the literature search than i
have
representative
you may answer that very briefly please
if you can uh
yeah it's very brief i do not know um
and actually i have to confess i am not
the one that did the deep literature
dive on this we have it was somebody
else in our committee a couple people in
our committee that did the deep dive on
this one um so i do not know if that
organization
has has a standing on this at all
thank you any other members of the
committee
i see no hands up i get no texts of
hands up so
again thank you dr cyrek
christina is there anyone else who
wishes to testify who did not sign in by
i do see two hands that are up in the
attendees list we have a rene demaris
and then new hampshire s
cpa sorry i did not hear you
two hands
who are they christina
renee demaris
well
i can pronounce rene demeris so i'll go
with her first
all right
hi um this is actually keenan blum from
prime alternative treatment center i
apologize i was using a co-worker's
laptop um are you able to hear me oh
yeah
thanks perfect thank you very much um uh
i don't want to repeat what dr cyric
said so um
so um i just wanted to um say a few
basic things
um
so um
you know we've been working with
patients for almost five years now and
insomnia is one of the most common
comorbid conditions that we encounter in
our current patient base uh who have all
been approved for other conditions when
a person can't sleep it affects nearly
every aspect of their health from their
mental health to their immune response
um in my personal experience if there's
one thing that cannabis works well for
it's inducing and maintaining sleep um
not that there aren't many other uses
but that is one of the key things that
ends up helping our patients as dr cyric
said get rest and really heal from
whichever condition they have it's good
for almost everything um many of the
products we offer are specifically
selected and designed for nighttime
which is really intended for uh to
promote sleep
um some are focused on quick onset and
short duration to assist patients in
falling asleep others are formulated for
a slower onset and longer duration to
keep people asleep
and we try to modulate the dosage
because
too much of that actually doesn't tend
to promote a restful sleep and good rest
so it's finding that right balance
usually below the level of intoxication
um which is able to allow someone to
fall asleep and to stay asleep
um many new hampshire residents could
benefit from access uh to the
therapeutic cannabis program for
treatment of insomnia uh many studies i
found that that seem to you know aim to
underestimate the rate of insomnia in
adults puts it at over 10 percent of the
population has chronic insomnia at one
section of their life or another
um and so overall prime atc supports hp
89 as it would allow much needed access
to legal regulated and tested cannabis
products many of which are specifically
targeted for sleep
um so thank you very much for for
listening to my testimony
thank you
for your testimony
and the christina the other one i i
believe it's a series of initials
standing for some organization
good morning can you hear me yes good
morning my name is robin abbott i am
um actually calling in from my work
computer which is the initials i'm a ceo
of a non-profit here in new hampshire
but i am the parent that representative
knurk was referring to earlier
in this testimony and thank you so much
representative knert for remembering my
testimony from last year
it was very emotional and it was very
heartfelt
my son is now 29 years old he is
a wonderful
just engaging
lovely young man who has come a long way
in his plight for
really growing and and being involved in
his community jonathan is six feet tall
and he is 168 pounds and as
representative conner referred to
we have had some um really challenging
moments with hissy fitz as an adult it's
been more than
quite a long road and let me also to
attest to the fact that we have gone
through
a variety of medical uh pharmaceutical
use
antipsychotics i have to have his
kidneys tested every year he's been on
opioids and and many of those psychotic
medications can lessen their effect over
time with the small use that we've had
with medical
cannabis therapeutic cannabis it has
been life-changing i am able to do
things with jonathan that i've never
been able to do before he's on a very
minimal dose
he's engaged in his community he can
tolerate change and changes in routine
which many of you may not know but
people on the autism spectrum disorder
have a really difficult time with this
and i will say the past two years our
lives have been completely
opened up to a whole new world
particularly for him i have friends who
also have adults with autism spectrum
disorders and they've told me that you
know issues such as seizures and and
dietary issues have been minimized
completely because of the small use of
medical marijuana so i just really want
to support this i'm here to
offer any other personal
um
testimony i i will say i was appointed
by governor lynch about 10 years ago to
serve on the autism commission the first
ever so i have been involved in many
aspects of asd
i've been involved in autism
now and organizations and
although this is a small component of
you know what happens as far as you know
some of the uses and and and
opportunities there are this has
probably been one that has affected our
lives positively more than anything so
i'm happy to take your questions i do
have written testimony i'd be happy to
send over
and i guess i'll leave it there and i
apologize i'm calling from my work
computer
thank you for your testimony anybody on
the committee with a question
representative gay i i really don't have
and we save any sharings for the exact
session okay
anyone with a question
[Music]
i see
two hands
and i'm going to guess that uh one of
them is representative folsom boy that
thank you mr chairman um i would really
like to
be able to receive that written
testimony
from uh ms abbott if i could
um i'd like to share it with some
friends
i would be happy to i also have
testimony from one of his direct care
professionals who's also noted an
immense change as well as my personal
friend um who has been using this with
her son he hasn't had a seizure in over
five years um and he's in his 30s so
there are many of us who this has been
life-changing i'd be happy to send it
over just please let me know um the best
mr mr chair could can can we give her
the address now to send that so that she
can do it
yes we may we can and may yes go
do you wish to or do you want me to you
can do it
okay uh renee it's h
l e g dot s t a t e
dot n h dot u s
so again h h s e a at
l e g dot s t a t e dot
nh dot u s
that sends a copy to everybody on this
committee including uh
representative folsom who is the clerk
who needs to have it for the record as
well and just ask for it
i get that okay
shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you miss
abbott um
your testimony was um extremely
compelling to me
um
who had questions someone who had
questions about um
this
so
i wonder if to be further compelling if
you know of any advocacy
organizations for autism spectrum
disorders that have taken a stand on
this either pro or con
to answer your question thank you for
that question i have heard some small or
um you know there autism speaks is the
primary one and i think they have
they're really looking at some of the um
best practices around services and adult
transition and there are many many
issues i'm sure as you can imagine with
autism spectrum disorder vocational
issues adult living you name it this is
not something necessarily that has come
up very much but i will say that more of
the um
more of the community is is looking at
this more closely because there are so
many people out there like myself and
families like ours that are seeing so
much benefit from it um and and let me
just say i you know my son is 29 i would
not recommend this first for someone you
know we can look at this from an age
perspective as far as as an adult and
more and more families who have an adult
child or an adult family member with
autism spectrum disorder are looking at
this more closely and i'm hearing more
and more
positive results
very few if any negative results
whatsoever
i i'm sorry that probably doesn't answer
your question it's the best one i have
at this time
i see no further hands
is there anyone else who
has lately signed
mr chair may i just go ahead and try to
help answer that question too
uh yes go ahead
okay just simply i went to autism speaks
i mean i looked it up they actually do
question are wondering whether or not
it's going to be helpful and they held a
consensus conference in 2018
about uh research on cannabis and autism
and they promised on a post in 2019
that they would be um
you know making the consensus available
later that year i find nothing on their
website on a search for anything more
recent or on a google search um
and so their final state statement was
until then we encourage you to discuss
cannabis products with your child's
health provider before trying them which
of course is the way it should work
anyway and precisely what therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board wishes
they did bring up also the concerns in
kids and that's why we set up an a much
higher barrier for under 21 because of
the developing brain so that's the best
i can come up with on that thank you
thank you and this is the last call for
questions from the committee and
all right seeing none of either one
i call this uh hearing to a close and i
would like to
move to exec this bill
the
items that we
believed we needed to change in the bill
are present in
representative kenner's amendment
unless there's somebody else who's
telling me
they wish to go get another amendment
um i don't see anybody telling me that
so then i'm going to open
the exact session on house bill 89 and
the protocol is to start with the
amendment
h and representative kenner and
co-sponsored by representative vail
representative connor could you speak to
your amendment please
yes sir mr chair i would be glad to do
so um i would like to first move
you 1-0-4-3-7-h to do that don't we
yes which is an amendment to hb89
second
second representative
mckay
okay
now
so again uh this just simply adds autism
spectrum disorder you know again i my
apologies for bringing in something that
was so different because particularly
for the public and uh we did get the
word out uh to miss abbott to hear her
compelling testimony but the issue is
we did place some rather
tough restrictions remember for any kid
under 18 you already have to have
a second opinion
of uh anyway you know so basically this
sets a really high bar for for kids or
anybody under 21 because of the
developing brain so it would not be
something that would you be used in a
you know willy-nilly fashion but for
over 21
we did not feel it necessary to have all
these extra special consultations so it
does expand the scope of this bill but
it becomes we thought this bill
the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board thought this bill would
provide a good opportunity
to be able to get asd back in since no
bill was
filed and it was too late when we found
that out for me to file one
i have a comment
uh yes
uh state your comment please
i i find this testimony very reassuring
this is exactly
the way it's supposed to work the
original commission five years that's
gone to sleep and this
professional
organization is providing exactly the
information
that we need to make
professional decisions so i find this
very reassuring
thank you representative mckay
am i open now
hey my my computer plays tricks on me
all the time
i find that com i find the testimony
here very compelling i did have one
question of representative kenner
frequently we talk about the human brain
only reaching its
ultimate state of maturity at age 25
is that
and yet we're using 21 as the cut off is
there any reason to be concerned about
that discrepancy
uh may i answer yes you may
uh yes well back when i was in my 50s my
wife contended that that maturation
didn't occur until age 60 but any case
[Laughter]
well that is a problem we did we did uh
work in this because it is
21 is not a magical age but we thought
that that was a reasonable compromise
because also
these
uh
here's what we don't know we don't know
whether the autism brain matures in a
wholly different fashion anyway
it's already an abnormally wired brain
if you will and we have no idea exactly
how it matures so for now we decided to
go with 21 because again by that time is
um
miss abbott
commented even even younger you begin to
have some real issues if you have a kid
who's having some real difficulty with
behavior um
so yes
we compromised on that one we didn't
know quite where to set that but decided
21 was reasonable
thank you
by the way oh may i just speak um
representative mckay is right you those
who were on the committee from a few
years ago remember that every single
time we were in testimony i understand
on any of these conditions i always
raise my hand and ask the same question
are legislators supposed to be making
these medical decisions and that is why
it is that we brought forth this bill to
create this board um and this board is
indeed functioning at a very high level
to provide the input so thank you for
that comment representative mckay
yes thank you mr chairman i will confess
to being all over the map on this issue
on the one hand um
my experience as a therapist working
with families
tells me that there are a lot of
negative impact
impacts for chronic
marijuana use and i think we often give
including increasing anxiety and
paranoia in people who use cannabis over
a long period of time
so on the other hand i think prohibition
of of cannabis has been such a disaster
that i think it should be completely
legalized across the board so i'm all
over the map about this um
i do think that since we are giving it
since we are using it as a medicine
we should be very careful about
how we do that
um
and i was ready to vote against this
amendment but i was convinced by
um ruth abbott's testimony and her
testimony about other people besides
herself and the little bit we were able
to learn about advocacy organizations so
i will support it
anyone else representative gay thank you
and i don't have to have a question not
this time okay
i really wanted to thank everyone who
testified especially about personal
experience because we all agreed with
you so much i'm assuming that everybody
felt as positively as i did
and so we don't ask questions and when
you make when you make testimony that
you've agonized over and nobody responds
it feels negative so i just wanted to
assure everybody who testified that it
was very compelling and i very much
appreciate it
thank you
see no one there's a hand jerry do i see
he's not ready he's got his real hand up
uh i see no one sorry i have my physical
[Music]
actually then to represent shapiro he is
absolutely correct and that is that was
our concern
about uh
using well anything anytime we use
cannabis and kids which is why again we
have a very small number of of kids who
are qualified
the one the problems is recreational
cannabis is often going to be used at a
much higher dose and much more
to fulfill other needs or other desires
of the person who's using it here when
it's used therapeutically
as i mentioned one other time in another
bill we start low and
then increase slowly for the desired
effect so for example five milligrams of
thc is a fairly small dose um and that
is indeed the difference between the
therapeutic program and recreational use
where we can have a better way to
on representative woods
thank you mr chair um uh to uh
representative shapiro's point i think
it's well taken
however i think they're they're in under
these circumstances there's a built-in
uh safety net in the sense that in
general there is a limit for the quotes
prescription length it's got to be
reviewed
and therefore and also the fact that
the
person
not prescribing
but providing the registered uh
individual
is
very tightly controlled and people that
are very familiar with any changes that
might be occurring
and i think they would ask and we can
assume
uh like any physician they would be
acting responsibly so the fact that
there is a fixed time frame
by which it has to be renewed and then
it would be have to be renewed by people
that are very specifically involved
professionally in this kind of
individual i think the safeguards are
there
i think the point's well taken but i
think the safeguards to my perspective
are there thank you
there is some debate as to the point to
which a member of the committee can also
keep answering questions in exact
session so i'm not going to call on
representative kenner as david scanlan
assistant secretary of state says when
you're winning stop arguing
so unless there is any other question or
statement on this from anyone else in
the committee
i would like the role to be called i
don't see any hands so would the clerk
please call the roll on amendment 2021
zero four three seven eight
moved by representative kenner seconded
by representative mckay
thank you uh representative marsh
yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson yes
representative acton
yes representative gay
yes
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes
representative king
representative kobalts yes
representative weber
yes
representative mckay
representative snow
yes
representative knurk
representative she had to step out okay
he he did mention that would happen from
time uh representative cannon yes
representative
uh nutter upham
yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant
yes
representative pearson
the vote is 20
yes
and one
absent
before i
call for the discussion on the bill as
amended
somebody from this committee
mentioned that
some committee chairs read the number of
people who signed in in support for
neutral or gads
and i know some committee chairs don't
but i don't think it's a
bad
there were 33
people signing in
in support
and since the copy i'm supplied has
their home town
the one who asked me
where do they come from all 33 of these
are new hampshire residents
zero
signed in in opposition
and one person representing an
organization signed in as neutral so 33
4 zero against one neutral
with that i introduce bill 89
fn as amended and i'm looking for
representative uh yes i will please move
that we pass uh we do otpa on hb 89 uh
with the amendment that we just passed
uh which the number i'm just suddenly
blanking on but in any case zero four
three seven eight zero four three seven
yes thank you
a second second
first
who said that first i saw canon
representative cannon
got it
now any further
discussion
seeing none
with the clerk please call the roll on
house bill 89 fn
amended by zero four three seven h moved
by representative kenner
seconded by representative
cannon
representative marsh
yes representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson
yes
representative acton
representative gang
yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
chelsea yes representative king
yes
representative cooper
representative weber yes
representative mccain
yes
representative snow yes
representative knert
yes
representative soloway absence
representative cannon
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods
yes
representative merchant
yes representative
yes pearson
is 24 passage one absent
mr chair i would move consent
uh we'll put this bill on consent
and representative kenner uh please
write the
report thank you
and with that i closed the exact session
on house bill 89 fn with amendment and i
opened the hearing on house bill 90
and we bring back representative vale
to introduce the bill of which she is
good morning again and thank you mr
chair and honorable committee members
i just want to make sure you can hear me
before i proceed
yes
thank you
this will be very fast i filed hb 90 as
a prime sponsor following the filing by
a member who was not reelected
the mistake i made was not reaffirming
that this is the right time for the bill
this evening last evening it came to
light during a phone call with the
person who would be providing testimony
that the time has come and gone for this
bill due to the oversupply in the market
which decreases the quality and makes
sourcing quality products much more
difficult
therefore i ask the committee to please
vote to itl the bill as it's not
relevant at this time and i can take any
representative there when i got your
email last night i spent a few minutes
thinking about
the times that i had put a bill in only
the asset of the ito for any number of
reasons and any of us who've been here
for a while have done this
so thank you
and i do have um representative nurk's
hand and i would like to call on him
thank you uh i'm sorry i missed the
email last night could you clarify
what you meant by the um
oversupply could you clarify that a
little bit more for me
certainly representative kirk uh canard
thank you for the question
the
you've probably seen that there's a lot
of cbd on the market it's on neon signs
over smoke shops it's in
in 7-elevens and at the time this bill
was in conception
it was
not at that that was not the case at all
and i believe that this would impact
negatively in fact because sourcing um
the quality products will be harder to
distinguish from those that have the
unknown compounds that i discussed in
the last
the
the difficulty is that the cbd we see
all over the place
is totally unregulated i have a separate
bill and we're not supposed to talk
about that but i have a separate billing
that looks at the regulation of the cbd
that is being marketed which is outside
of the atcs
because this one was for in the atc's i
do not have this since the
this is not a medical question therefore
tcmob did not make a comment about this
i'm hoping we have
um michael holt on this
who would be able to testify a little
bit more about it but
it's important to understand that it's
totally different that the market for
cbd
um
in you know the corner grocery store and
everywhere else is totally unregulated
some of them don't even contain cbd even
though they claim they do they're not
tested for impurities or iron or i'm
sorry or cadmium or mercury or
pesticides some are some are reliable
but there's it's an unregulated market
so um hopefully we'll hear more from
representatives sorry from michael holt
about whether this is helpful or not to
am i to answer this question as a
follow-up mr chair
if you wish i see michael holt is
has signed up i do not know if he's in
the meeting and can be called up um if
he wishes to when he if he's here and if
he wishes to would he put his hand up
please but yes representative there go
for it
i was just
i just wanted to take it further by
saying that when an outside product so
this would be introducing an outside
product an outside source
for medication that will be made and
distributed in the
dispensary
therefore it will have to be tested and
it will have to be determined to be
a proper source
because of all the unknowns that are
coming up with changes in the program
and legislation that may be in the other
body at this time
all of the factors considered
the um the hemp cbd is an oversupply and
it just makes a really difficult time
for us to get something that we can
really test and have that that solid
integrity that we're used to by having
the self-contained and the um the
self-sourced um model that we're using
for the tcp
thank you did we find representative
uh
sorry mr holt anywhere uh yes um my name
is michael holt can you hear me yes mr
hall thank you
thank you for the record my name is
michael holt i'm the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program with
the department of health and human
services
the department does not take a position
on this bill i can provide some
background um and what we really need to
hear from is uh the atc's if they are on
the call as well um because they would
be able to provide the testimony
to say whether or not this bill is uh
needed or helpful
my understanding um so first to the bill
language um the bill does require any uh
outsourced um cbd product isolate
product to be tested in accordance with
new hampshire uh law and rules um not
only the concentrate isolate itself but
also the products made from it
thus ensuring a high quality product um
and um
free of contaminants per uh new
hampshire rule
um the origin of this i believe and i
believe the atcs can testify to this a
little better is that um
is that
the seeds plants grow differently the
the
the atcs have expressed a need to
outsource cbd because they cannot
produce enough of it it within
their current production facilities so
this would be a value to them to be able
to provide a wider range of cbd products
um for their patients
than they can currently
provide
i believe that
we can accomplish
this
in a safe manner but again it would be
up to the atcs to testify whether or not
this is uh is still needed
and i would i would i'm happy to answer
i see no hands up
or
any text indicating this anybody from
the committee
uh is michael mclaughlin here
he is listed as representing the
sanctuary alternative treatment center
so this may answer mr holt's um
desire of having somebody from an atc is
mr mclaughlin
i am trying to can you hear me now as
you say a little louder would be better
please
can you hear me now
much better thank you good morning
members of the committee and my name is
michael mccarthy i am lobbyist and
conquered and represented sanctuary abc
by error i signed in in favor that means
to be louder
i did by era i signed in and favored the
bill this morning but i talked to the uh
i clan earlier and they indicated they
were against the bill so i did not hear
michael holt's discussion uh
i was on a phone call but we are not in
favor of the bill they do not like the
thought of bringing out of state uh
canadian into the system
said they're not
he doesn't like the idea of out-of-state
products
all the materials that we provide to our
patients are manufactured in the state
tested in the state under strict control
so they're not comfortable with material
i don't see any thank you for stepping
up uh
both you and mr holt
the chair sees only one other person
signed up to testify and remember the
sponsor of the bill wishes we itlet
having signed up before that revelation
in favor of the bill is representative
wendy thomas
um
i may be i may be live this is keenan
blum from prime atc here um
am i am i being hurt at the moment
i don't see wendy on the list here hi
yeah well
um
co-hosts more representative pearson yes
who are you looking for
for representative wendy thomas
yeah she's not on the attendees list
right now
okay she has she has uh is there anyone
yes
christina
there's nobody else on the list but
there are several people with their
hands
raised um are they from the committee
no they're not okay thank you
and mr chairman i note that the
screen assigned to renee demaris has the
person behind that screen is asked
several times if they may speak
they're already in the meeting
okay uh but you but
is not the protocol that you sign up to
i have not got the update i know there
was some changes contemplated about
last minute without the leave of the
i'll take i'll take i'll take two only
so wendy demaris i think it was it
yes thank you
um are you or is everyone able to hear
me oh yeah yes thank you um this is
keenan blum again from prime atc thank
you for calling on me i i did sign up
for hb hp 90 uh to speak on this um i'm
not sure if it came through properly um
but
um
i want to thank everyone for their their
time today um
you know our we've reconsidered on this
bill originally we were very much in
support of it um you know especially a
couple years ago seeing the ability to
more efficiently grow hemp outdoors uh
versus utilizing power indoors to do it
however um watching the
cbd isolate and and um the hemp industry
nationwide over the last few years it
has resulted in a large number of
you know kind of inconsistent and in
many cases mediocre products that do not
meet our standards
now while we are able to formulate this
isolate and these compounds into
successful products
we also
you know want to continue to do what
we're doing which is producing
everything we make in-house in new
hampshire
using employees from new hampshire and
the resources in new hampshire
and i think we have concerns at this
point with
the a kind of slippery slope of bringing
in products from outside that group
whether we test them here to confirm or
not i i would certainly be open and i
think um i can't speak for the other
atc's but i think we would be open
if we were able to produce it in new
hampshire
we under a known circumstance that we
were able to oversee throughout the
process or be involved with throughout
the process i think we could see
utilizing hemp cbd
which would allow us to cultivate or
allow a partner to cultivate outdoors or
in a greenhouse which isn't really
currently uh possible under the
regulations for the therapeutic cannabis
program the security and other aspects
of how it's written make that
impractical however
for cbd in this scenario
we are able to keep up at this point uh
with our business with our cbd needs
we after finishing a large cultivation
build out and we believe that we can
continue to do so in the future under uh
basically under
uh an environment and under a situation
where we take absolute uh pride in the
quality the cleanliness and everything
we do so at this point
i think the preference of prime atc
would be to cultivate
everything in-house um and to reconsider
if we are able to oversee an outdoor
hemp cbd
process and cultivation process
so if anyone has any questions i'm happy
to answer them but otherwise thank you
very much for giving me the time to
speak the chair recognizes
representative folsom
hello oh thank you very much chair um
this is just a technicality issue the
clerk would really not like to have the
full name of the last person who
testified and where he's from because it
doesn't match what's on the screen for
me
and i need it for the record
my apologies um my name is keenan blum
that's
k-e-e-n-a-n
and the last name is blum
i'm the president and ceo of the
non-profit prime alternative treatment
center
thank you very much
let me ask again christina is there
no i don't see anyone on the list thank
you very much and i will close the
hearing on hb
90 and in order to keep to our schedule
we will
close the hearing and we will have to
execute it at a later time which could
[Music]
now open the hearing on house bill 599
relative to the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board
uh point of point of order mr chairman
it's it's 10 20. i don't think you can
open a hearing scheduled for 10 30 at 10
20.
10 30. we're absolutely correct and i
think
i would be delighted to make a motion if
you would care to open an executive
session on uh house bill 90. yeah
is is there any is there any sentiment
in the room that you
want to sit on this for a week or you
want to bring back
amendments or or are we good to go
whichever way we choose to vote are we
good to go on
executing
looks like well and i i do thank the
honorable gentlelady for that uh not
only because she's correct but
we can get this job done so with that um
[Music]
i'd be glad to make a motion
who is speaking yes yes please make a
motion
uh i think you have to open the
executive session first if we didn't do
that yet i do
and since i think i opened 5.99 but
incorrectly it doesn't
count and now i will open the executive
station
house bill
90 and recognize the gentlelady from
17 i forget your towns but
to make a motion
thank you it's the gentlelady from
walpole and uh i would move itl on house
bill 90 on the basis that
it was very much wanted when it was
introduced situations have changed and
it now appears that it is not as useful
as it might have been at an earlier time
so i move itl
representative march seconds four
seconds
now discussions which can be
not questions
i think i've discussed it as much as it
does anybody else
and see no hands and um
trying to keep up with what i was asked
to do there were 10 people who decided
for support
of the original bill
as to pass
there was one person who signed in to
oppose it passing and that was the prime
sponsor
and everyone listed lists the home
address as new hampshire
well my name is matthew snow i want to
cancel my
representative acting please
well i guess
okay hang on a second let me just mute
the background sound here mute
representative acton you're recording
okay uh thank you mr chair and uh thank
you committee members
i i'm just a little bit confused here so
i want to just take a step back to make
sure that we're
we all understand what's going on here
uh when this first came in
several years ago it was based on on the
lack of availability of of quality
hemp products within the state
i believe that's changing somebody can
correct me if not
we now have a hemp
program in the state that's actually
functional
so that
what i think i'm seeing here is that
atc's are now starting to grow their own
hemp in state that they weren't allowed
to do
even
last year or the year before i know unh
has been pushing for hemp production and
so forth
so that seems to be
moving forward so
i'll agree to the itl but i but i am
worried that we've only heard from one
atc and and i'm assuming that they're
producing their own so they've started
their own hemp production
in
business in
in concert with their atc but i really
would love to hear more
from to mescal and
the other atc's as to if if they aren't
doing this
are they going to be hampered by not
being able to source their own
cbd's and then in essence this is a
business model
issue
between atcs versus
a solution to the problem where the
where the
thank you representative representative
weber
i would say that um i believe we heard
from two different
industry representatives and
representative clerk is giving me a
victory sign which i think means that he
agrees with me
and uh then the other thing is that this
is a properly noticed public hearing
members who want to talk about something
have a duty
members the public who want to talk
about something have a duty to sign up
and make their wishes known
i don't think it is the business of the
committee
uh except in very
specific and and i think narrow cases to
go out looking for people unless unless
serious questions have been raised about
the way we're going i mean it just seems
to me axiomatic at this point that the
sponsor doesn't want the bill the two
people who are here
from the industry don't want the bill
and and we've heard testimony
from um
the regulating authority
as to why it may not be needed anymore
so
my thought would be to go ahead but
that's just me
okay
follow up if i could mr chairman yes
representative actor i
the only reason why i'm asking is this
itl changeover came in last night so
they may not even know so that that's
the issue um but you know
these problems have a tendency of of
working themselves out it doesn't always
require us to pass laws and that uh
seems like the situation we're in here
so
that's all i need to say thank you
i might observe that it's been my
experience and sometimes it's a good
thing to show up
even if it looks like it's slammed up in
your favor because things have a way of
changing and on a couple of occasions i
am so glad
i appeared when i thought i didn't need
to but it proved i really did
and
there is no other person on the even on
the in list one way or the other about
the bill
so
representative webber's point is very
well taken
i see representative
i think it's conner
in the upper left corner
yes um yes thank you and i i agree uh
whether they thought it was gonna be an
ital or not if they had a concern they
would be here and the only reason i
raised alarms in the beginning was
because it was fundamentally so
different than it was the previous year
but i think we've heard very compelling
testimony that we actually don't need
this now and so i agree with
representing weber that we should
proceed with an itl and i think we can
be comfortable doing it at this point
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
um my only comment is that you know just
because we don't need this now i mean i
think it it broadens the freedom of what
these a
alternative treatment centers can do
and just because it's not
needed now there may be changes in the
market
and
the the reasoning behind it
is still a little bit unclear for me
why they're against it just because they
don't need it um
i'm just inclined to
broaden freedom of this industry to
to acquire
um
these these have derived
um cbd isolates from elsewhere if they
seeing no further hands from the
committee
the
itl
moved by representative weber seconded
by representative marsh on house bill 90
would the clerk please call the roll
thank you mr chair
representative marsh
yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson
yes
representative acton
representative gay
yes representative cushman
yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king
yes
representative
thank you representative webber yes
representative mckay
senators know you need to unmute yeah
yes
thank you
representative kenner
yes
representative soloway
i believe he's still absent
representative cannon yes
representative nutter of them yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes
representative merchants
yes
representative pearson
yes that's 20 in favor of the motion and
one absent
representative webber would you
care to write the
majority report i would mr chairman and
that um this
uh
closes the exact session on hospital
night
and the chair recognizes a 10-minute
recess
and
future
yeah just
you know considering it afterwards yeah
they may not need it now but why is
there
i wonder
you know
what i mean
exactly that's what i was thinking i was
[Music]
this
you
uh
um
okay
wow
sorry i forgot to tell you guys how to
do that
the person who
the person who has done that in the past
is at home so but we figured it got a
couple people
gifted in
intuitive
well thank you
and
asked
texted
and done all that's in the runner
to find out when our remaining meetings
will be
and we know march 2nd is one
but i am told that we shall be informed
late this morning when that is when i
know you'll know
so we can plan our lives
with that i open the hearing to house
bill 599 fn relative to the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board
and i call on the
prime sponsor our very own
representative
okay uh thank you mr chair and good
morning again everyone
um so i have to admit um i didn't write
this bill it was transferred to me and
we're at the very end of a
um
we're at the very end of a long
process where we've gone through a lot
of uh therapeutic cannabis bills
um this year and and i have to admit
that this once looked through the cracks
um it's
i didn't understand
some of the legislation and i received
some very marked
um
input on how it is not going to work and
i'll allow the people who testify
to explain but i think the best course
of action here is an itl so um i will uh
close my remarks and and allow others to
um including i believe michael holt to
comment on this and we can proceed thank
you
okay i trust there's no questions from
so with that
we will
thank you very much um can the committee
thank you
um for the record my name is michael
holt i'm the administrator of the
therapeutic cannabis program
uh the the department does register
opposition to this bill i thought that
my testimony would come after
representative canerx to be honest
as he is the chair of the tcmob
um but i can provide some introductory
remarks here
this bill would create a duplicate
conflicting requirement for the clinical
review of all existing qualifying
medical conditions
for the therapeutic use of cannabis
currently this clinical review
responsibility belongs to the 13-member
board which is charged with the
responsibility of reviewing current and
new medical conditions and making
recommendations to add or remove them
from law
under the current statutory model such
recommendations to add or remove a
condition would be made to the
commissioner of hhs who could then
choose to seek legislation to add or
remove those conditions this bill
proposes a duplicate conflicting
responsibility for the review of all
existing conditions places it on a
single individual the medical director
of dhhs with no additional appropriation
for resources requires that information
to be reported within 90 days of the
bill's passage to the joint legislative
oversight committee on health and human
services it's a duplicate process
it's a conflicting
requirement that is
envisioned in the current law
considering that there are 21 identified
medical diagnoses a catch-all that could
include any medical diagnosis and 10
associated qualifying symptoms and any
combination thereof it's simply not
feasible for such a review to be
undertaken by a single person with no
additional resources and completed
within a 90-day time frame
the second thing that this bill does is
creates a
or adds a conflict of interest provision
for these board members again this is a
duplicate
requirement with the financial
disclosure requirements already required
for this board under rsa 15a established
establishes an additional requirement
where members of the board would need to
identify any financial disclosures at
board meetings before taking actions um
on on
a
topic that comes up during a meeting so
it's additional um it's redundant work
but it's also a higher standard than
other boards and commissions in the
state for these reasons the department
opposes this bill
happy to take
questions for
seeing none
there was a very good reason why the
chair did not immediately recognize
representative kenner
i read my paper wrong
okay
thank you very much i yes indeed um i've
already told you who i am representing
jerry kinnick representative carroll
county three um and that i'm the chair
of the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board we've already talked
about who they are
again 599 is an unnecessary and
unworkable bill reflecting the lack of
knowledge of the complexities of
decision making and how the tcmob
functions
as we said this puts a review which is
duplicative and 90-day period by the
chief medical officer um which contrary
to what stated in the bill he is not the
chairperson of the board i'm currently
the chair but the issue is that the
proper evaluation of a qualifying
condition requires a lot more
consideration of that
you've heard my testimony on other
conditions and discussed some of the
detailed processes we follow we usually
start with a discussion at a board
meeting we appoint a subcommittee to go
do a deep dive in the literature because
since we have a number of different
medical specialties involved they can
look at the ones for the area they know
best they then report back to the board
of the subsequent meeting we hold a
public hearing for example that's what
we got to hear from miss abbott that
testified in the previous bill and then
we put up together a total draft report
the subcommittee does a draft report
combining that scientific evidence and
the hearing testimony
that's presented to the full board we
then discuss it and sometimes we even
take more than one meeting to really
finally come down with some language we
draft language to cover special
considerations
and then finalize a recommendation to
the legislature it functions the tcmov
functions very well and is very diligent
utilizing their personal experience
legislative reviews or sorry literature
reviews and testimonials from the
patients to make its recommendations
so it really just doesn't make sense we
already have evaluated a number of
different conditions i think it's five
all together mostly at the behest of
bills that have come in but we are
planning to start working on the other
things this last year we focused on
the educational program so we didn't get
a lot done on other uh
pulling up already approved
conditions
uh the second part yes is unnecessary
and it does hold we already submit
financial disclosure forms i don't have
to do it because i do it through the
legislation right through the
legislature and
the
the requirement of having to disclose
before every action is indeed a higher
level not only for other boards but it's
a higher level than we hold our
legislators to
and the issue is that the inclusion of
participation of representatives of the
atc's
and of the provi of providers who do
certify
is to balance that we also have
providers who are very very skeptical
excuse me
skeptical about therapeutic cannabis and
so we end up with quite a diversity of
opinions which makes chairing the
beatings
really interesting because we really
have
a very just uh
very important points of view that are
brought in from all sides and that that
requirement sorry that uh is actually a
strength of this and so it's not a
conflict of interest it's negative it's
a conflict it's a
it's a positive tension that it adds to
the board in terms of its work that it
does sony i urge you to
move itl on this bill because it really
enhampers the ability of pm tcmob to
make sound scientific discussions which
take into account the needs of the
patients the needs of the providers
the atc's and the therapeutic cannabis
i see a hand up along the bottom but i
is there anyone on the committee who
okay um we i will allow uh mr holt to
again
is there a question for me i have no
okay
that was left over sorry
anyone else
is there anyone else anywhere that is
signed up i've got everyone off my list
is there anyone else
there is no one left thank you very much
in that case i closed the hearing on
house bill 599
and i open the executive session
on it and representative acton would you
care to make a motion on the bill
thank you mr chair i would like to move
that we uh broke this
bill
uh in expedient to legislate
all right and you had a co-sponsor on
that bill as i see
and um the co-sponsor who is me
who is i uh wishes to second
now any discussion this can be sentences
acton
okay just uh real quick um
like i said this came in in a flurry of
of bills we were kind of just
grabbing them and taking them over and
seeing
which one worked uh for each of us
um and in in this case i was already
overextended this came in
and i should have caught some of these
things beforehand um it's not a good
idea to
use the hearing as a way to vet a bill
but um i do apologize for that and
certainly to michael holt who i've
worked with for years and years as an
activist and a and the legislature a
legislator and also to dr ballard who
was i believe was very much against us
so live and learn let's move on but this
we have a forest then an executive
session house bill 599
the motion is itl
made by representative acton seconded by
the chair and with no further discussion
or questions
being seen would the clerk please call
the role
thank you mr chair
representative marsh yes
representative mcmahon
yes
representative nelson
representative acton yes
representative gay
yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes
representative king
yes representative kobalt
yes
representative weber
representative mckay
yes
thank you
representative yes
representative soloway
absent
representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
shapiro yes
representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes representative pearson
it passes uh 20 to zero with one absent
and without objection on consent
and would representative acton please
write the report
i will have that to you uh by the end of
the day thank you very much and with
that i'll close the year of the
executive session on 5.99
and we'll take about a two-minute uh
chairman we can't start up again until
uh
11 15 oh unless you want us back for
executive session let me do that for the
do you want us back in five minutes for
an executive session or do you want us
back at um 1 15.
i want you back 11 15 i'm sorry
no
uh
yes
[Music]
how you get the wider screen you just do
it so as you move it closer and you
start losing that perspective
so then
mhm
okay
[Music]
means is that some kind of a date it's a
plural form of you accepted south of the
mason dixon what is the plural form of
you all
you all is plural
if you want to emphasize that you really
want to be inclusive
or if you're angry
okay we've got about 15 minutes and um i
chief of staff to the speaker has
informed me that what we already know
is next week we meet on
tuesday march 2nd
and the following week
we meet on monday
with a backup day of thursday march 11th
that's the last day we all turned
set
anything just got out the door
we're in trouble
we may not need march 11 but if we need
it we got it
and i am reminding myself that that
means march 8th
docket's batting order has to be in
by noon on wednesday because of how the
calendar works
so march 3rd excuse me march 2nd tuesday
march 8th monday and march 11th thursday
i'd like to take up an exact session now
and i opened this exact section on house
bill 582
we have been holding it for an amendment
from representative shapiro
which
is
in hand
this is relative to the descriptions of
the treatment of attention deficit
disorder
or attention deficit disorder with
hyperactivity
you may remember that representative
marybet walls presented this and our own
representative woods to the co-sponsor
on house bill 582 which is amendment
h
representative
i'm not sure that's the correct
amendment thank you mr chairman um
oh
it is the correct amendment thank you mr
chairman um as um as i imagine people
remember this is a
bill which allows which initially was
meant to extend
um the prescription supply of
[Music]
to 90-day supplies instead of
60-day supplies and that was to improve
the continuity of care
to decrease co-payments and really as a
convenience for families who were um
constantly having to restock these
medications so
the amendment
really was um
just adds narcolepsy which um is treated
with the same medications and and
includes narcolepsy for a 90-day supply
as well
now when i submitted this amendment they
didn't write it ex precisely as i um
asked them to
um
but i think i was being too much of a
perfectionist and i think it's probably
adequate i'm going to ask representative
merchant as a pharmacist to comment on
it but my concern is that it covers
there are five subcategories of add
including um
inattentive type with hyperactivity and
impulsivity combined type not otherwise
specified so i'd like to ask
representative merchant if he could
comment on the way this is written which
is the way that was written in the
original bill
would be adequate for pharmacists um
getting these prescriptions to include
all the different subtypes of abd what i
ask representative shapiro is that you
move the amendment and it's seconded and
then we can discuss it we will call up
okay
i thought i did but maybe i didn't i
0408 for house bill 582
i'll second it
who is that
weber
thank you very much
now the chair calls on representative
merchants
thank you mr chairman
um to speak to the issue of concern that
representative farrell has as a
pharmacist it's actually written i think
appropriately um we're not getting into
sub-categories of a diagnosis we're
looking at things at the macro level and
i think at that point in time where it
belongs is not try to get into the
sub-therapeutic diagnosis so the way the
bill is written today i as a pharmacist
i'm sorry for my old years you please
trailed off are you are you saying the
amendment is okay the amendment's okay
the way it's written actually is is
preferred because it's actually at the
macro level um versus getting into the
sub-therapeutics of sub-diagnosis if you
will under the macro
um so therefore i will support the bill
actually the amendment to the bill and
the bill itself
any further questions from the sponsor
of the amendment
on
amendment
2021-0408-h the amendment to house bill
582.
removed by bureau second and by that
thank you mr chair
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson yes
representative acton
yes
representative gay yes
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king
yes representative cofolt
yes representative weber yes
representative mckay
yes
representative snow
representative knurk
yes
representative salloway
representative cannon
yes
representative nutter uppim yes
representative shapiro
representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes and representative pearson yes
it passes 20 to zero with one absent
the chair now recognizes representative
woods who is the co-sponsor of the
original bill for a motion
yes i uh offer
uh that we pass um
uh house bill
582 as amended uh with uh amendment zero
representative march seconds
court may call the role on house bill
582 as amended by
2021-0
airplane h moved by representative wood
seconded by representative
thank you mr chair representative marsh
votes yes representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson yes representative
acton yes representative gay yes
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
[Music]
representative cofoult
yes
representative weber
yes representative mckay
yes representative snow
yes
representative soloway absent
representative cannon
yes
representative nutter upon yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods
yes representative merchant
yes
representative pearson
it passes twenty to zero one absence
and representative woods if you would
write the majority report and without
objection it goes on consent
uh will indeed do sir
i don't think we can beat the time
record on that one so uh we're gonna
we're just gonna look at each other for
four minutes and 34 seconds before uh
house bill 146 comes up at its schedule
time of 1 15.
uh in the meantime the people meeting in
the legislative office building have
received a hard copy of representative
marsha's amendment to house bill 605
and as we might be executing that in the
afternoon
if that came into your computers
you can either download it print it out
now look at it now it's very brief or
you could do that over the lunch hour
i just want everybody to know how really
bitter i am looking out the window at
this gorgeous warm sunny day and here we
are
all stuck in our various inside slots
but
um needs must so here we go
feeling like a sprint out there though
yeah take yourself outside
add to that four inches of fresh powder
for those of us who like to
cross-country ski in a beautiful day
like today
well i was thinking that among other
things the speaker's office that with
all the money they're saving on mileage
and toll remissions
the whole committee could go to florida
social distance we can bring our pets we
can
i was shown which way the door was so it
was not going to happen you forgot to
invite them
darn
yep but i had to go out and scrape the
snow off the panel so it would really
work well it's still working still
working on shedding the part i couldn't
get yeah we were lucky enough not to get
that much snow so it's gone
so your panels are not on the seat on
the roof
my my solar panels are on the on the
roof but we only got less than an inch
we put taps into our trees on sunday
because at least in the massachusetts
border it's going to be in the 40s
that's true
weber you're already in florida
yeah really look at that i do my poor
best
and growth in the right direction
it's great and then when you prune the
summer it's to kind of back you
know actually for joe who's a fellow
gardener i've already started greens to
do a spring an early spring transplant
into the greenhouse next week and i
started peas inside and i just
transplanted those out last night to the
greenhouse and it's about 80 degrees in
there today
big enough
and if we pass home grow you can start
oh never mind
[Laughter]
i got a big lettuce factory going in my
basement under the lights right now it's
actually nice to have fresh lettuce
yeah it is we in the greenhouse i'm
loaded with lettuce and we have fresh
salad every single night it's fabulous
we bought the house it had a greenhouse
added to one side of the garage but the
previous owner planted trees in front of
it
and so um this summer the job is going
to be cutting all those trees down and
then adding solar panels above the
greenhouse area so um
that that's our goal for that's our
project this summer
be cautious about one thing when you put
the solar panels there they do shed snow
a lot better than a roof and they'll
shut it right out of the greenhouse
which may be
yeah our greenhouse is domed
good
so it's it uh i mean it's it's a very
wonderful greenhouse yeah um
and why
they planted these trees there
i have no clue
they weren't thinking no they they
definitely were not
declares it's not only 11 15 somewhere
it's 11 15 here
and with that i open the hearing on
house bill 146 requiring health care
providers to furnish upon request a list
of ingredients contained in an
injectable medication that is
recommended or
administered
hello hello
great uh good morning mr chair and
honorable committee members uh my name
is representative barbara contoir
representing belknap 7
we're all concerned about what we put
into our bodies with food so why
wouldn't we not want to know what is
being injected into our bodies
when researching the web just looking
for a list of ingredients in a tetanus
shop
shop there is more than one manufacturer
and the only the active ingredients were
listed
so my question is what is the makeup of
the inactive ingredients and do they
differ from manufacturer to manufacture
so all this still does is if you're a
patient or a legal guardian and you want
to know
what the health care provider or person
giving an injection is
and you ask them they need to furnish
you with a list of all ingredients
i think it's important
they don't have to furnish it to
everyone but only those who ask
some of us read our labels on our food
and some of us don't
any questions from the committee for the
sponsor
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question am i right in
understanding that you are
not requiring a label you're just
requiring that the list of ingredients
be
furnished either on an internet or or by
request
rather than having to label every
individual product is that correct
thank you for the question uh
representative weber um so when you go
to the doctors and you they want say a
tetanus shot because every one of us
needs one of those every 10 years
and they say you know it's time for your
tetanus shot
well what's in the tetanus shot
we don't have any way of knowing
so
i'm just asking that the physician or
whoever's furnishing that injection to
you you can ask them i'd like to see a
list of the ingredients
um
okay
i see uh representative merchants
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um the way this is written
you help me explain this healthcare
provider
that would be encompassing all health
care providers including a dentist even
a veterinarian um
plus it would also include all locations
of health care whether it be a hospital
an urgent care center an emergency room
and so forth is that
help me understand to clarify that for
me
uh thank you for the question so it was
my intention um
with with the writing of this bill
is that if you go to whether it's your
doctor
uh clinic or even
the pharmacy and they want to give you
an injection
you should have the right to know what's
in that injection
so it's
what i my intent was is that anyone
that's gonna gonna give you an injection
you can request it's not mandated that
um that they have to supply it to
everyone it's only for those people who
all of it for me yes you may yes so
would you see that impeding the patient
care where all of a sudden the provider
doesn't have the information to treat
the patient
i'm thinking about a hospital setting
even an urgent care setting where the
patient requested
but the provider may not have all the
information that's one concern number
two
within the manufacturing of
pharmaceutical products
it's not uncommon for the inactive
ingredients sometimes to change from
manufacturer to manufacturer which could
put an onus on to the provider and being
able to timely provide care to the
patient
thank you thank you for the question and
i understand what you're saying
but if i'm getting a shot and i
understand that and that was one of the
things i brought up but is it the the
ingredients do change from manufacturers
to manufacture
but shouldn't the person giving an
injection know what what's in that
injection
how do they know that you may not have a
an allergic reaction to something that's
in
to one of those ingredients
i mean isn't there due diligence to do
that
to know that
so
my question is why don't they already
uh the chair recognizes himself for a
question uh representative
is do you is it not the case now
increasingly
in restaurants and in some cases by law
they have to let you know on the menu if
there's
peanuts in the kitchen if there's
something that many people have an
allergy to on the menu somewhere and
isn't it increasingly the case
in previous years that uh people selling
canned goods had to let you know
everything you know frozen foods
so isn't it the case that what you're
just suggesting is yeah if it involves
work they're gonna have to do what
everybody else did
in restaurants in selling groceries
that's what that was do you do you think
that's parallel
uh thank you mr chair and yes i do and
um you know we even went so far in them
with the meat industry as saying that we
even wanted to know what country things
were coming from
um
so
it's not
they already know it's in the
ingredients that are in their products
and they should be supplying that we we
should have the right to know and
depending on what you when i started the
web some people supplied both the active
and inactive ingredients and some didn't
it was a very interesting research uh
when i when i did that but because we
don't know which manufacturer or what's
being injected into us you know we don't
we can't make a um
informative decision on what's going to
work best for us for the patient
thank you representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking this question
um
generally i'm in favor of um consumers
right to know
especially what they're ingesting i'm
curious as to why
this bill just covers um injections and
not medication taken
orally uh thank you thank you for the
question um i do believe and i'm not
positive because i don't take a lot of
medication um but i believe when you get
your medication you have a lift i mean
you get like five pages of i believe
what the act what the ingredients are
and all the side effects when you go and
get an injection you get nothing you get
the shot that's it
and possible
may be a list of side effects
but i may be wrong regarding the
medications
follow up please
so i guess my question was really if you
were if somebody was a hospital patient
and they were given medication orally
then
i think it would really
might be the same situation
um
as an injection um another question i
have do you know
this is alluding to representative
merchants question do you know
how readily available these ingredients
are for
clinicians who are providing these
medications and practically speaking
what will it take to make this bill work
thank you for the question it is my
understanding that the pharmaceutical
companies have to provide
the ingredients to
the people that they're selling their
product
shame on us
but i do believe that is happening and
this bill and i'll allude to your
question uh regarding taking oral
medications in a hospital
um
you're you're absolutely correct you
don't know what's in those and we're
just take those upon faith and i can
tell you from personal experience that
after having an emergency surgery
my recovery period was hindered by some
of the medication that i was given
and i had no idea what was in that
so going forward i wouldn't even know
where to begin to look at something that
representative merchant asked my
question thank you
welcome representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and thank you uh
representative for taking my question
uh uh the first i have two and i'll ask
for a follow-up if i can uh line seven
it says any health care provider who
recommends
or
administers
so i'm thinking about the practicalities
um uh you come to my office um and uh
you have a particular condition
and uh the treatment modalities are such
that um you need a particular uh
injectable which i don't have but i know
one of my uh colleagues
has that and so i recommend that you go
i don't have the medication i don't do
the injection
but that puts an onus on me
just by virtue of recommending
could you comment on how that would play
thank you representative for the
question uh the reason i put down
recommend in there was because when i go
to the doctors
and they say hey you know it we'd like
to give you this shot and my question is
is well what's in it
and they're just recommending that i
take it they're not telling me i have to
take it
but they're recommending it
and before i can make an informative
decision i want to know what's in that
product it's kind of like when i look at
food i read the labels because i want to
make sure
i want to know what i'm eating
so that is why the word recommend is
there
follow-up representative
thank you i understand
the concern and i agree that you should
be able to do that
however again just reflecting
i may not have that information
uh and the the individual who would give
you the shot
um
would have that so i i i i have some
trouble with that the sec the second
part of the uh
um
lost my train of thought here for a
second uh uh carry on i'll think of it
in a second
[Music]
we will come back to you if you wish
thank you and just as a quick follow-up
to representative woods um first line of
inquiry
i'm wondering about the
administration side
when the administration is done by
somebody
i mean i had my arm jabbed last week by
a member of the national guard who
probably doesn't know or have access to
the ingredients
in a particular shot
but is perfectly capable of
administering a shot
under
you know certain supervised conditions
so
i'm wondering if you could be thinking
about a way of dealing with the fact
that some of the people not only do some
of the people who recommend the shots
not have the information but some of the
people who administer the shots may also
not have the administ
the information and i don't know how to
fix that but i thought maybe you might
want to think about it a bit thank you
thank you for that and i understand your
concern
um
but if the shots are being
uh handed out to
say the person that's administering it
why couldn't the pharmaceutical company
send a list of ingredient sheets with
those
uh injectables along
so that
copies could be made
follow-up
my concern is that
that could happen but the bill does not
require that to happen the bill requires
somebody else to do something with
information that they might not have so
i'm wondering if you could just think
about ways of perhaps
clarifying that whole process thank you
thank you and i will certainly give it a
look
representative woods are you back with
your second question i i tickled my bet
cells and uh
they reconnected
um thank you uh representative i'm
getting uh uh carrying on with uh the uh
comment from uh uh representative
shapiro um in the emergency room um
let's let's pretend that it's two in the
morning
and in the process of uh ongoing
treatment which may have started six
hours before
um and uh you need an injection of such
and such and you inquire
um
that creates an issue
um uh
there's different pharmacies uh i mean
uh different uh providers for the same
uh item and uh the um preservatives uh
and what are called the vehicles
are different for those preparations
however when it goes to the hospital
it doesn't go
uh to
down to the emergency room all the
emergency room is gets all they get is
the vial
all of the
insert information that you're talking
about that you get when you get a
prescription at the pharmacy is not
there
uh so
now we're at two in the morning
and you need some uh injectable
um and you inquire
this may delay uh for some time uh maybe
hours uh until that information uh is
available
um is there some way and again
representative weber alluded to this as
well
that we could rethink this
and maybe clarify how this plays out
both with the
line 7 recommends as well as the issues
in
the emergency room and
you know i think we can take a look at
that but you have this is not a mandate
this is not mandating
that they have to supply it to everybody
only those people that inquire
um and for me
i would want to know what preservatives
are being put injected into my body and
for me a delay
is okay
for some people a delay may not be okay
and they may be okay with saying yep
just give me the shot
um
so i think it's
i think we have to look at it from that
perspective because not everybody
a lot of people are going to take
the injection or they're going to take
the medicine and they don't even look at
it
i mean people buy their groceries or
their food and they don't ever read the
label
um
but there is a certain set of the
population where it's very important
because
of bad reactions that they have had
uh in the past and i think that's
important
i'm not i know that doesn't probably
answer the question
but i don't have a
representative marsh
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question um
and this is uh
a little bit complicated but as you know
we have an academic medical center in
the state of new hampshire at dartmouth
and they do medical research there
and one of the things that is done in
medical research facilities is we have
double-blind studies
where we try to find out if a new
medication works or not
and what happens is people who sign up
for these studies either get
what's being studied or they get what's
called a placebo and nobody on the team
and the patient doesn't know which one
they get until the results are collated
at the end and then they can figure out
whether this medication is actually a
useful medication to bring further
forward
it's the intent here to break the code
so that if somebody in the study asks
which arm am i in
you have to tell them
or should we make an exception for
thank you for the question and i believe
that if somebody wants to be part of
a test group then an exception should be
made
thank you
representative
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you very much uh representative contour
for my questions uh would you be
like would you like to amend
to address these many issues
um i'm seeing several
whereas
mentioning active and inactive
ingredients
um
how to give a list to a person who
requests like do we want to say
they can request a hard copy because we
don't want to say oh sure here's the
link to it you can go home and read it
um
if people need
like would you consider
um
expecting the supply the
provider who is providing the
medication
would they
have to have
a printer
handy so that online they could
just
just asked to print it
just as needed they wouldn't have to
have a stack of papers to hand out but
they would have access to a file online
that they could as requested
um
it sounds you know are you interested in
amending so that we can address all
these issues
thank you representative and yes i would
be uh very interested in that and
interested in working with the committee
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative compost for taking my
question would would we be able to
satisfy the need
uh for the information you require with
an online
uh look up on the internet and and i
asked that because
my daughter is a formulation
bioscientist for pfizer and the
information associated with the pfizer
vaccine for kovit is is all listed on
the
internet
including
multiple depth of information as
required by the fda and other
organizations around the world so the
information is readily available
by manufacturer and would that satisfy
the need
thank you representative for taking uh
for the question so i did i looked up
the fights of the vaccine for pfizer and
you're absolutely correct all the active
and inactive ingredients are listed
however
when i looked up tetanus booster or
tetanus shot
there was uh several manufacturers and
only some of the active ingredients were
listed the inactive gradients were not
so
so to answer your questions that unless
we knew
what
was right there and the other the other
question is if we can't get a list
when they want to give us the shots
then it's going to make a delay where if
you had a printout or something to look
at on a screen in the in the doctor's
office you would see those ingredients
immediately
representative
very much um
representative woods laid out a scenario
a little while ago about
two in the morning in the emergency room
um and you made a comment that you
really wouldn't mind if your treatment
was delayed but would you agree that in
a busy emergency room or
provider's office
that
this will delay
these kinds of activities might not just
delay the care of the person that
requests but the care of other people
are waiting to be taken care of
and that maybe there might be better
ways to transmit this information
thank you for the question and
i understand
what you're saying and there may be some
delays but i don't think the delays
would be that great
um
because
as i've said
you know
sometimes there's inactive ingredients
or even some of the active ingredients
that you might know have an adverse
effect on you
and
the doctor might not realize that or the
person giving it might not realize that
and it so it is to the health of the
patient
representative nelson
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question do
you know if they would list a scientific
name
versus an everyday name uh you know i'll
use uh wheat i don't know if there's a
scientific name for wheat you know which
thank you for the question and i didn't
get i i understand what you're saying
because really some of the names are
really tough to uh discern uh for the
layperson but i wasn't going to go into
the weeds with all of this i was just
asking for a list of the active and
inactive ingredients
thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
um if i go back to the issue about food
if i buy the food in the grocery store
it of course has a list of what's in
the container of the product i'm buying
however if i go to a restaurant i don't
have in the menu manual list of all the
things that are in the food products
that the chef used to prepare
the meal what i'd be concerned about and
trying to get to the root here is if i
had a peanut allergy i would inform the
staff at the restaurant i have a peanut
allergy and ask them
does the food that you're serving me
have any peanuts in it or any nut
contain it so it puts the illness back
onto the restaurant to at that point in
time ensure that
if i have an allergy to a peanut or to
something of whatever the food may be
the restaurant's informed about that and
they have to make the decision that the
food or what they're providing to me is
not going to contain something i'm
allergic to
would that be something amenable to in
saying that if you tell the provider i
have an allergy
to something
that will cause a problem harm to the
patient
that the provider then is informed and
the provider has to make the
determination the product they're going
to give to you is in fact
void of that particular chemical
thank you for the question
and
going out to dinner is an option
getting an injection may not be
and
you can choose where you go to dinner
based on the food that they provide what
you know about the restaurant and some
restaurants do list where they're
getting their food from
uh they actually list where the farms
that it's being brought from
if you are so inclined to uh go to those
places
so that is
a choice we're talking about something
that somebody wants to administer into
your body
that's not it
i mean i have rejected injections
because i don't know what's in them my
doctor keeps insisting i need it but
until i can get that lift i am not
taking that injection
so it may be to the detriment to my
health but that's okay with me because i
i see representative nelson's hand is up
i no longer see it but i
do see representative marsh
uh yes this is another question
i'm trying to think about how the spill
might affect other products and one of
the things that we have seen in medicine
is we've seen a huge infla increase in
the number of conditions that can be
treated uh due to biological products
that are available we've debated bills
about biosimilars in this committee in
the past and one of the things that the
fda tells us about biologics is that
they aren't like drugs where they're
manufactured from ingredients but they
uh they they compare the
biological activity of these things that
are being manufactured so i'm not sure
that the ingredients are actually even
known for uh biologicals uh and i'm
my question is have you considered uh
such products in this bill or should we
just make an exception for that
thank you uh representative and no i i
did not consider that i am
not
a doctor or in in the medical field at
all so i was not even
uh i didn't really look into that at all
so
thank you
representative woods
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
again uh um could you help me out uh
could you give me an example of
something that might be listed in an
injection
that would catch your eye
that would
precipitate
a no
for an injection i'm i'm kind of curious
i thank you for the question and no i
cannot because i've never actually been
given a list of anything that's been
given to me or when i was in the
hospital for emergency surgery given a
list of any of those
uh medications that were given to me
so i don't know i couldn't tell you
which ingredients
follow up yes yeah thank you um
is there a class of
chemicals that you would be looking for
is there any indicator
at all that as you
interact with the provider that's going
to give this injection that you know
ahead of time like a peanut allergy is
is there something that you are looking
for
uh thank you representative no there is
nothing specific that i'm looking for i
just think that it is
the patient's right
to know what's being injected into their
body
i think we as consumers want to know
what we're eating in our food and we
demand that labels are put on our food
so that we know
what's in that
and what is the difference between
consuming something and having something
injected into you
why wouldn't you want to know what's
being injected into you versus what
seeing none the chair calls on nick
dougherty
he's from boston
and the home of the champion red sox
and he is a lobbyist with the
pharmaceutical research and
manufacturers of america
and he is signed in in opposition to the
bill
uh mr door
i just want to make sure can everyone
hear me
okay perfect
uh so thank you for having me today uh
as mentioned my name is nick doherty i'm
the director of policy at pharma for the
new england region and i am face down in
boston
the pharmaceutical research and
manufacturers of america
represents the country's leading
innovative biopharmaceutical research
companies which are devoted to
discovering and developing medicines
that enable patients to live longer
healthier and more productive lives
since 2000 farmer member companies have
invested nearly 1 trillion dollars in
the search for new treatment and cures
including an estimated 83 billion in
2019 alone
now prior to coming on i've had an
opportunity to listen to the discussion
uh with the committee it's been very
informative um and also gave me an
opportunity to
to uh search the internet um
during the discussion um now i am here
to testify in opposition to house bill
146 and that is because pharma believes
it's unnecessary and also may be
preempted by
existing federal law under the federal
food drug and cosmetic act
the statement that we did submit to the
committee provides a lot more detail of
the federal laws already in place that
address ingredients on prescription
labels and for the sake of time
and just
in response to some of the questions
i'll try to adjust address the general
ideas here
so the fdca regulations already require
drug labels to identify each active and
inactive ingredients on a label
any label that does not conform to these
requirements would be considered
misbranded and subject to fda
enforcement
now the fdca regulations also expressly
include exceptions for listing inactive
ingredients
that would
result in divulging trade secrets and
when it's just trace amounts of harmless
substances that are added for
identification of the product
now because house bill 146 does not
contain a parallel exception to either
fdca requirements
this proposal would create a conflict
between the state and federal law
which is the reason why we believe it
would be preempted by existing federal
law but in addition to the preemption
issues and i think this is where a lot
of the conversation was happening today
there are two websites where this
information could be found the
ingredient information both active and
inactive could be found online
the first one is the nih
daily med database
so this would allow anyone while i was
sitting here i was i did search a couple
of my medicines to see if they were on
there so anyone from patients caregivers
health care providers and members of the
public can search
in a number of different ways it's
either by drug
by the national drug code so every drug
has an ndc
or by drug class or by a set id
so that is i believe it was rep nelson
asked the question about how you could
search so scientific name would be one
way
or or ndc which is uh
on every bottle or or information that
is provided to a patient
uh and then the other way to do this on
the fda website there's also a database
that allows for searches by both active
and inactive ingredients
so for those reasons we are opposed to
the bill i'm happy to take any questions
uh from any of the committee members uh
to try to provide further information
i have a question mr dougherty this is
the chairman mark pearson um if the
search on the websites that you
mentioned um
i believe you i've never done it but i i
believe you then it shouldn't be very
difficult for somebody in a doctor's
office to do the same when a patient
wants uh something injected should it
correct so the the doctor would be able
to sit at their desk or on a smartphone
and and go to that website and and um
in search
based on an nbc
thank you anyone else from the committee
somebody's saying
um i see it looks like representative
kanark
thank you uh mr daugherty would you then
agree that if a person has a specific
concern
that it would be less cumbersome on a
practice for them to go seek this
information at the websites you've
quoted rather than to ask a provider who
then has to
stop the work in their office to look up
this information and provide it to the
patient would that be a more efficient
way for this for a given person who's
worried to find that information
i i can't speak to which would be more
efficient but the the opportunity would
be available in either way uh always a
fan of having multiple bites at the
apple so it could be a review in the
doctor's office or the care
the patient could look on their own or
have a parental guardian or caregiver
i don't see a yellow hand but i see a
a larger hand from mr acton
representative acton do you have a
question uh thank you mr chairman
because i'm in the host mode i i can't
seem to raise my hand so i'll
put my own big hand up there but anyway
uh
[Applause]
uh mr dory couldn't this be handled as
simply as as the industry creates a
clearinghouse of
an online database of all this
information and simply just hand the
person who asks a business card that
gives them login information and then
provide them that
provide them all the data they want
isn't it could it be that simple
you don't even need login information uh
i just this is a public website um that
anyone can log into uh in the testimony
that we included
you can click uh in the link click
click the website and it'll bring you
directly to the location where you can
look up
any drug based upon you know the class
the ndc or an id number so it's not not
anything that's exclusive to the
manufacturers it's it's publicly
available
thank you mr chairman but uh
representative acton
asked the question
a representative gay
uh yes sir thank you for taking my
question what exactly is the website
name that has the nbc class scientific
name etc
so if you were to look at the uh
testimony that we presented it's the nih
dot com
so dailymed dot
n
so daily med no no spaces nothing
d-a-i-y
seeing no other questions thank you mr
dougherty for your testimony thank you
for having me
the chair now recognizes douglas phelan
and your email address
indicates you are with
elliott-hs which i would conclude as
assistance
and so we recognize represent uh mr
story
hello is this uh is this working yeah
it's very good
uh good morning mr chairman honorable
representatives thank you for the
opportunity to testify today my name is
douglas fallon i am an attending family
medicine and preventive medicine
physician practicing in bedford new
hampshire
and i'm a resident of salem new
hampshire i'm speaking on behalf of
myself today in opposition of hb 146.
i posit to you that the potential harm
this bill seeks to protect against which
is if i'm interpreting right the
administration of an injectable
pharmaceutical without providing
information as requested by the patient
or patient's proxy
that this is already protected against
we are bound by our vocation as
healthcare providers to act ethically in
the care of our patients
if that binding does not suffice
we are also bound to the new hampshire
board of medicine to abide by the rules
of the board and as referenced by the
board the american medical association
code of ethics
ultimately an autonomous patient can
agree to treatment or decline it
and after discussion with the provider
and after requesting any information
that is additional it follows that the
request is integral to the decision it's
important to the patient and so we
providers provide it
furthermore uh by federal law from 1986
we furnish at every vaccine
administration a vis or vaccine
information statement
notably i'm sure the officers are aware
this does not include ingredients
however even though it's not in the vis
we still provide it when asked because
our patient expressed that it's
important to them in their decision
i was trained at what was for 20 years
the only family medicine residency in
this state
i can tell you that we are trained to
answer patient questions
it would not for example be good care if
a patient asked me for information and i
declined to provide it while continuing
to then go on to administer the
treatment
in addition to my care for a panel of
2200 patients and my experience in an
office that cares for nearly 17 000
granite staters
i have not seen any account of refusing
patients information when requested in
this manner
through my involvement with organized
medicine in the state i have also not
seen any report that this is happening
on any larger scale as well
additionally the regulatory burden that
this imposes
for a harm that is to me neither
apparent nor on the horizon
is high and it poses the potential for
more burden i can furnish the list of
ingredients and i already do when i'm
asked
they come with the pharmaceuticals
they are also widely available as we've
heard
keeping paper copies of any list will
take time updating and vaccines and
injectable medications are also
administered beyond the auspices of a
provider's office
furthermore i'd like to have
in consideration that i'm under no such
requirement to furnish a list of all
medication ingredients for other
pharmaceuticals we discussed the active
ingredient
but this has also been addressed already
by the representatives thus far with
regards to pharmacy administration but
there was the point raised about
hospital administration of oral
medications
the last and potentially most important
arguments i would make are those of
patient autonomy and the paramount
importance of the patient provider
relationship
to me there should be a material need to
insert government into the medical exam
room to make mandatory policies that
would impact the care a patient receives
at status quo patients and their
providers discuss treatments the content
of those discussions is part of the
beauty and the bedrock of medical
practice based in the inherent autonomy
of the patient
the health care decisions that arise
come from shared decision-making models
between the patient and their designated
medical professional
and for me when government inserts
itself into that practice there should
be a very clear need and for me when i
look at this when patients request
information they should receive the
information based under the current
regulatory paradigms that exist and so
because of that i speak in opposition of
hb 146 and i thank everybody for their
time
will you take questions
yes
while others decide if they have
questions
i have a semi question
that is i dropped
a primary care physician as mine
because the doc in the box facility in
which he worked made him see so many
patients per day
the questions were not encouraged
oh there's nothing that i could quote in
a lawsuit that is very apparent he
didn't have time he was not allowed to
have time
to answer questions such as what's in
this medicine you've prescribed me
and while
i very much am
in favor of keeping government out of
things as much as possible
i had a bad experience which is why i
left that primary care person i've heard
similar stories
so
where is my recourse there other than
changing pcps which is what i did
i think
unfortunately uh that is a story that we
hear from patients i've heard it from
patients switching to me and i i know
that that is not unique and it's very
hard and i'm i'm sorry for you and
everybody who experiences that with
certain offices
i would say that this is similar to any
other course of treatment right if you
are not comfortable with a course of
treatment that you and your provider
formulate through shared decision making
then we have the right to seek
uh seek recourse
elsewhere through other through other
means
this isn't i we heard the
gentleman who was speaking before me
from public testimony
had indicated that you know this
information is out there so for me when
patients ask it's not too hard for me to
get that information
i know that there are some offices that
offer stricter time requirements than i
am forced to uh to comply with
however at the end of the day my
responsibility is to my
my oath as a physician and to my
licensure
as well as first and foremost my patient
and if i was in a situation where i
wasn't able to make uh good shared
decisions with a patient i probably be
would be looking for a different
thank you so much for that statement i
appreciate that very much
as the ceo of small healthcare facility
i really do appreciate that thank you
anyone from the committee with a
question for i am going to assume dr
phelan
i
see
no hands
up
so thank you dr phelan for your
testimony
christina is there anyone else who has
signed in who did not make the list who
i do not see anyone additional
well then i close this hearing exactly
at 12 noon
yeah and um
declare a half an hour lunch break and
ask you all to be back here at 12 30 so
we can do some executing up until our
one o'clock hearing because remember
we're going to be adjourning early today
because many of you have another meeting
um joe uh shapiro can i ask you a
question
can you hear me
i know i can okay um the uh dental uh
round table this afternoon
um
is what levels that i know a fair amount
about it
um is that something i could benefit
sorry i guess the senate organizes these
kinds of things so i i looked at one of
the other ones they did it's about um
you know they did one on uh mental
health the um emergency room waiting
issue and they did one on i think on
education and now they're they're just
doing these on
um
you know current topics and so
it's a half an hour
and myself and cindy rosenwald and
somebody from the new hampshire
coalition
are going to speak for a few minutes
[Music]
i mean i don't i don't
you know you might be able to find out
for example what happened at the hearing
of the senate bill which happened last
week but
i don't think for someone who knows
who's knowledgeable about this i don't
think there's going to be too much new
[Music]
just a reminder as we get going
we meet again on tuesday march 2nd
and i've said sent you
already the agenda
we will meet again on monday march 8th
and i've got to get the agenda in
because it has to go in next week's
calendar
and if need be we will meet on thursday
march 11th which is the last day
we have left to get things out of the
door i'm hoping we won't need that day
but if we do
it's going to be available
uh can you folks hear me i think we got
unmuted
then i am opening an exact section
session
on house bill 220
and we start with amendments
2021-0334
written on february 11th
by representative marsh and
representative marsh if you could
present your amendment please
uh
yes thank you
and uh before i begin may i officially
move uh that we adopt amendment zero
three three four h and then i'd like to
speak to my motion
uh yes
thank you for the reminder
is there a second
representative betty gay second set
now we leave
thank you uh
the
purpose of house bill 220 is to
elaborate in statute that every person
has their right
to natural
essential and inherent right to bodily
integrity and that applies to medical
treatments and i i personally believe
that the
that has been implicit in the statutes
for a long time but it makes it explicit
in the statutes the problem with the
bill as we received it is it was rather
unworkable for a variety of reasons
and the most obvious example
is when you consider how it would affect
the involuntary emergency admission
process for people who are going to be
admitted to the mental hospital because
they are a threat to themselves or
others
clearly if it's involuntary
that is not something that they are
consenting to and clearly as most of us
know because we wrote the laws uh at
some time uh
the
rights of people going through that
process are very well protected um
so we need to
make an exception in the
in this new statute so that those
processes that we've already put in
place
to respect the rights of the individuals
involved in them
while getting the treatment that they
need
continue to work as they work at this
point in time so we made a number of
exceptions to this
we made an exception for involuntary
admissions
we made
an exception uh in that vaccinations are
required as a prerequisite for
admissions to schools which then people
uh or their parents
voluntarily comply with so they can
actually go to school and go to school
safely
and we have made exceptions for the
commissioners authority to authorize to
order treatments pursuant to the
infectious disease statute and also to
the pursuant to the venereal disease
statute
last one of the concerns of the people
who brought this bill before us
was the
um
before i go to that we also have
occasions in law where people have
appointed guardians to make their
clinical decisions for them and we
needed to make an exception for that so
that process can can continue to happen
in the way it does now
last one of the concerns of the people
who brought this bill before us were
that they thought that they were being
required to have certain vaccinations as
a condition of employment when i
investigated this i i
discovered that certain people have been
terminated from employment for refusing
vaccinations and when these cases are
appealed on to the
federal equal employment opportunity
commission
they're educated under
a
rule that's that's in federal statute
that i referenced at the end of this
amendment specifically if there's not an
immediate threat
that this requirement is addressing then
they are determined to have been
terminated without cause and receive
appropriate benefits there too by
putting that same standard into statute
we're going to make it so people have
the benefit of that protection without
going through the long and drawn-out
process and expensive process
of appealing to the equal appointment
opportunity commission so i i believe
that this amendment makes the the house
bill 220 workable um
and uh still maintains the original
intent of
representative lang who brought it
before us to
make explicit in statute that people
have the right to their own bodily
integrity so thank you for that
representative woods you have a question
for representative marsh
i do uh thank you mr chair and thank you
representative march
i i did pull up uh the definitions as
you've referred to with the cfrs
uh it's still rather vague
um and i
i guess it's
supposed to be vague i guess
um help me out
i run a company
uh i've got 30 employees
uh they work it's a semi manufacturing
area
uh they're very close
in terms of uh proximity to each other
manufacturing manufacturing process just
by virtue of the nature of the product
um
an individual applies
vaccinated
thinking back to the situation i think
it was north or south dakota with the
meat packing plants
and
the individual says no
and i said i can't take the risk for the
rest of my
staff
where might that play out
i i think that there's a difference
between choosing not to hire somebody
and choosing to terminate somebody who's
currently under your employment so let
because it's a clearer question perhaps
you're working in a meat processing
plant one of your employees refuses the
vaccination at this point in time the
covert vaccination is not an fda
approved vaccination and i believe that
problematic if you terminated them for
refusing to take a vaccination that is
uh currently only authorized under an
emergency use authorization now uh until
that entirely plays out under the
economic
the equal opportunity employment
commission i don't think we have that
benefit of the prior rulings but
by making reference to that statute
we're basically trying to follow the
follow-up yes um and this is an exec
session so it does not have to be a
question
thank you um
you alluded to not fda approved
however the eua is a form of fda
approval it follows
the legislation
for the fda to provide
this kind of approval so in a certain
sense
they have four two forms of approval
one is the full formal approval which
meets certain criteria the second is
approval uh for the eua so in a sense
uh it would follow under at least my
understanding is
and again that's what lawyers are for i
guess uh the fda um
is still approving it even though it's
eua it's under a different protocol
is that your understanding as well
my understanding is that i thought it
would be good to have state law parallel
federal law in this instance and i agree
that the lawyers are continuing to argue
about it and whatever we decide they're
probably going to continue to do so
but this way we are making a standard
that is neither stricter nor less strict
thank you
i
agree that this makes the
uh legislation considerably better so i
will certainly vote for the amendment
all of my concerns about the original
legislation still remain and i
i i think it um somewhat ironic that i
am sitting here
arguing the free market in that i think
that employers ought to be able to set
their
requirements and then people ought to be
able to decide whether they want to meet
them and be employed by that employer or
not meet them and be employed somewhere
else
um
but
you know
life is full of ironies
i'm really concerned about the situation
in which i
will undoubtedly find myself at some
point in my life i live alone i might
need personal care
personal services whether it be
housekeeping or actual
physical care
and if i am presented by two different
people who
might seek my
job
i'm for darn sure going to employ the
one who has chosen to be vaccinated
rather than one who has chosen not to be
vaccinated
as a matter of my personal safety and my
personal choices and i don't want
anybody to get vaccinated that doesn't
want to be i get it that they have their
personal choice but i think that this
bill skews the personal choice far too
far
in in the opposite direction and i think
that
people have their own personal choices
and they
as mr
boy this committee is bringing my old
teachers to my mind but as mr schwartz
used to say you gotta make choices and
then you gotta live with them
um
and and i really think that that's
that's true and so i think the bill goes
too far i i think the amendment makes it
better but i don't think the amendment
representative
thank you my read of
the cfr
might resolve the concern for
representative weber because it does
talk about the employer
uh who has
this it affects people who have 15 or
more employees so it does sound like a
person who is small might be able to set
a rule
but more importantly as we look at the
direct threat this is what makes me feel
a little more comfortable
i agree with representative woods it's
vague but the sentence says significant
risk of substantial harm to the health
or safety of the individual or others
that cannot be eliminated or reduced by
reasonable accommodation so
because the one i worry about the most
is a healthcare facility being able to
ask that somebody who wishes to have
direct patient contact
be
vaccinated for let's say covet or for
flu
and it would seem like um
that there's not really a good
reasonable accommodation sure are things
we can try to do for source spread for a
person who's working with somebody else
but they certainly still will present a
threat to their patient if they are not
vaccinated and indeed get either covert
or flu either one and these are people
who are going to be a very unique risk
because they are not in the hospital
because they're healthy usually
and
as a result reading this
at least the language as i see it um
this still would allow an employer to be
able to
fire or not hire somebody because they
say look we can't reasonably accommodate
you as a nurse in this intensive care
unit uh
if you are not vaccinated for
pick your disease covet or flu some type
of true transmissible um
so i'm i'm not at first i wasn't happy
with this but i think the reading of
this is so squishy
and i guess i'd really love to have
representative weber's thought because
she is the token attorney on the
committee as to whether or not that does
mean that it would still allow
an employer
to
fire a person who refused to get
vaccinated if they were in a position of
directly potentially harming a patient
um
and i
remember yeah so i was wondering uh okay
headphones are back on representative
mark if you alluded to the fact that it
hasn't occurred
do you say that then that
healthcare facilities have not been able
to tell somebody that they have to have
a flu shot to work in there
it is my understanding that the equal
employment opportunity commission held
that in the time of h1n1 that people who
were fired because they refused the
vaccine at that time were uh
entitled to benefits so i believe that
at that point in time that's what they
determined and i believe that more
recent rulings may be different and this
is subject to some change
and and i don't have a problem with that
because i think that as we understand
ken you're muted
are you trying to undo
i think he just hit the leave meeting
button instead no he did oh there he is
no he's still there just got rid of
video
if the host presses the request to
unmute button representative snow will
get
an unmute button right on the front of
i said that
and now he's muted again he muted again
ken
let's send him some stickers could you
send it yeah and can you hear us oh
there you go there you go
you're good i'm sorry this
i gotta buy a new i gotta buy a new ipad
i guess but anyway
is the amendment that we're talking
about the correct number o three three
four h is that the one that we're
discussing today
[Music]
yes
representative nelson
thank you mr
chairman i miss part of this
conversation but i think the question i
have let's use the school system in
chicago for example the union does not
want them to go back
what would happen if the nursing home
union or something pushes this
uh we're not going to come back unless
you would they have the rights over
the people who the facility
or the teachers union have more rights
thank you mr chairman
i do support
the amendment to house bills due to
i believe it
doesn't solve all the issues but it does
address many of the concerns i had
when i look at the federal statute
specifically 29
cfr
1630.2r
it does talk about the issue of a direct
threat
so it is defined to a certain degree
within the statute the federal statute
about what a direct threat is
answer i think the question that
representative nelson raised
if
there's a difference between having
my opinion a threat to an organization
versus an organization wanting to have a
standard for employment so if the
standard for employment was to have a
vaccination as part of that versus a
threat to the organization i think it's
a different
take on it this doesn't deal with the
standards it deals with threat to the
organization and also the employees
within the organization so it kind of
looks at the individual rights versus
the rights of all the other employees
within the organization i think
basically if the employer
determines that the threat everyone else
in the organization outweighs the
individual rights that's when this would
thank you mr chair um
um this amendment and um
as a school board member i recognize
that uh
29 cfr 1630.2
r
is focused
in on school children
but as a city employer of the teachers
we have had situations where we've
already had teachers come down with
with covet and they've been asked to go
quarantine
instead of staying in school to teach
we also have
a memo of understanding with the
teachers union
that they won't come back to school
fully until we meet certain white
criteria
um
i'm i'm struggling with this bill and
how we as a school board can get our
children back children and their
teachers back to school safely
i'm kind of
uh interested in that discussing 29 cfr
1630.2
and using the examples of being
not vaccinated
should you you know what are their
rights
other people
like people in the hospital
or kids
in this case the i'd say the elephant in
the room but to be fair is an elephant a
donkey in the room
the real concern here is we're talking
about covet because that's our direct
concern right now
as my
my understanding is that cova does not
fit the bill here you can have the
vaccine it protects you from getting
sick but you can still transmit
that really changes the story about
representative merchant hey i was just
talking to him said it's a scam
i got this bill
paul who was not muted would you please
mute
the representative um
i think i called on representative
thank you i i i still
i have looked at the direct threat
language
and i agree that i i will i will take it
on faith that it applies only when there
are 15 or more um employees because
that's somewhere else in the statute and
i haven't had a chance to up and down on
that but
i i still don't think that this strikes
the right balance for me i mean i think
that the amendment is better but my
concern is that normal
have a
uh an employer and they set out what are
the
uh core functions of a job and i'm sort
of thinking for purposes of ada and
other things but you know there are jobs
where you need to be there at 8 30 in
the morning because you're the
receptionist and you need to be
there both to let people in the door and
to answer the telephone and then there
are other jobs where it doesn't matter
whether you come in at eight o'clock or
whether you come in at 10 o'clock as
long as your work gets done
but i i really think that what this does
is
it
shifts
the analysis
so far
in favor of
the person who is refusing to get
vaccinated
that it takes away
a significant amount of the autonomy of
employers over
how they want to set up their work says
space and how they
uh intend to make a safe space not only
for the unvaccinated person but all the
other employees
and then all the people that all the
other employees go
and breathe on or whatever it is that
we're talking about at the time
um and i think that
if we pass this bill even with the
exceptions this statement
is
um
so broad initially
and now i have i'm i'm sorry i have the
cfr on my other device rather than the
actual bill but i think the statement in
the original bill is so broad even with
the exceptions that we are going to find
it covers situations that are are going
to make us very uncomfortable
so that's
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
um
so
the discussion that we're having is
that
you know the cfr um
reference and this
this amendment is
um
what i'm hearing from
my friends across the aisle is that it's
not
doesn't leave enough freedom to the
employers but i would argue that it
really isn't changing anything that
happens in our state if people
if someone gets fired
currently
for refusing to receive a vaccine from
uh
you know
in contrast to an employer's policy
their their
ability to address that
you know and seek redress for that is by
going through the eeoc and filing a
complaint
and
um hoping that they
receive a ruling on in their favor
and that's this what's in this bill is
not is not going to change that this
bill is addressing government mandating
vaccination
that's the whole point of the bill
and
you know
this referencing the cfr
just keeps things the same way that they
are with with employers in respect to
employees
representative merchants
what i'm looking for is
in the amendment
there's the employment
once you're employed and there's also
pre-employment
so does the amendment as written apply
to both pre-employment as well as
post-employment
in other words can an employer
have a mandate that you have to have a
certain
whatever may be to be a condition about
employment
would they still
be allowed to do that
which is different than a threat once
you are employed so i look at the threat
as current employees
that all of a sudden something is going
to threaten the organization and
therefore the employer thinks for the
benefit of the whole
we need to do something
which is different than
prior employment but the employer
decides the employee in order to be
hired has to have a certain
representative
thank you mr chairman
um
i guess looking at this amendment i i do
believe that it addresses the
uh you know potential concerns and
conflicts in the law
so i thank representative marsh for
having uh for having put together the
amendment
um
for what it's worth i
i'm just a tad bit uncomfortable with
the with the provision regarding direct
threat because i think that the
the the language there is
a bit too ambiguous having said that i i
will vote for the amendment because i
i would like this bill to pass i think
it's important i guess the
um
you know the the the point i would make
is that the decision to be vaccinated or
not vaccinated is not a trivial decision
i think that they're among many people
who
want the vaccine and intend to get the
vaccine
and here i'm talking about covid but it
could be any vaccine
i think the attitude is very much that
it isn't that big a deal what's the
problem why wouldn't you want to do this
i can speak personally that for me the
decision to not
um get the coveted vaccine in particular
is a it comes from a deep deeply held
personal belief
there are people who have very serious
concerns about the
the safety and efficacy of of that
particular vaccine and other vaccines
and i think that
as such
this bill intends to protect people's
rights to bodily integrity
their right to exercise their personally
held belief and puts the burden on
employers and others to
demonstrate um that there is a
compelling need for uh to to require
uh
any particular medical treatment
including immunization
we do restrict employers um
ability to
um
to impose certain employment
requirements or or standards
uh that have nothing to do with the job
um this is this is common
um and and i think that's a good thing
um if it doesn't have if somebody's life
decisions don't have anything to do with
their ability to perform the job um i i
think the employer does not you know
should not be uh should not be dictating
that
um so so i guess that you know that
really is what drives my
um
my decision on this uh which is that we
we really need to protect people's uh
people's right to make that decision for
themselves
barring as is outlined in this amendment
a compelling case on the on the part of
an employer
that it is necessary to uh to to deal
thank you mr chairman and i
maybe i'm
anticipating and going back to the
um bill when i shouldn't but i think
that
uh the
in in the context of the discussion of
direct threat and all the rest of the
exceptions here i think we all need to
bear firmly in mind that the underlying
bill does not talk about
uh solely about immunizations it says
including immunizations but
it requires that you can't be
discriminated against on the basis of
any unwanted medical interventions and i
wonder if people who require masks to
enter their stores
would be held not to be able to do that
because it's an unwanted
medical intervention for somebody who
does not want to wear a mask they
do store keepers hospitals and other
places hospitals obviously you can say
that there is a direct medical necessity
and i think it probably would satisfy
the tests under the cfr that we're
talking about but i think that there are
other places where
you know getting into that kind of
litigation every single time
somebody decides they want to require a
mask as opposed to a vaccination
is a very real potential under this
under this bill so
[Music]
enormous concern to me thank you
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
again going back to um the sponsor and
what he was saying on this bill um it's
not
to
you know impose new regulations on
places of public accommodation it is
just for the sake of those who are
tuning in for the one o'clock hearing on
house bill 605
we're almost there
but we're not on 605 at the moment we
are doing an executive session on house
bill 220.
i see no further hands i'm just going to
uh yes further hand webber
representative
representative weber you're muted
you you just muted yourself again
commuted again
all right sorry about that
um in in response to representative
cushman's point
if that is what we want to be doing we
need to say that because this says no
person may discriminate
no one may discriminate it's not limited
to government so if we want to ensure
that it's only government intrusion that
we are preventing then we need another
amendment that says we are preventing
the blanket that we have here
mr chairman may i raise my hand uh you
may in a minute representative marsha
i'm about to ask you if you would like
another bite at the apple if you
want us to accept this in the next three
four minutes or if you would like uh
to bring us a different amendment
addressing these concerns what is your
pleasure i i think at this time this
amendment is satisfactorily i will point
out to people there's been a lot of talk
about discrimination the word
discrimination does not appear here
anywhere uh it's merely uh
saying that people can't be compelled to
have medical interventions uh so uh i'm
content to go with this amendment as it
stands right now
the representative wishes to roll the
dice on house bill 220 amendment
h moved by representative moore seconded
by representative guy would the clerk
call the roll on the amendment please
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative nelson
yes representative acton
yes representative gang
yes
representative cushman
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king
yes
representative copel
representative weber yes
representative mccain yes representative
snow
uh representative cannon yes
representative nutter um yes
representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchants
yes
and representative pearson yes
the amendment passes 20 to zero with one
absence
now we um
are looking at house bill 220 amended
the amendment it becomes
almost the entire reveal the only part
it doesn't is on the
uh effective date which is 60 days after
passage everything else the amendment
replaces the bill
i hope we don't have a long conversation
because we've talked about most of it
but we do have a few things that could
my
concern and of course in unmuting myself
i've gotten rid of my text to the bill
again
the concern that i have is we have left
section one it doesn't replace section
one of the bill
and the second section sentence despite
what representative marsh just told you
the second sentence of section one which
still exists is
no person
may be discriminated against
for refusal to accept an unwanted
medical intervention including
immunization it is not limited to
who is or is not doing the
discriminating and it applies to every
person so that's pretty darn broad and i
just want to be sure that everybody
understands that's what they're voting
for if they're voting for it and that
that language is why i'm not voting for
it because it doesn't confine things to
the govern
government intervention it means
everybody
well representative uh weber i would
i would ask you please to look at the
amendment i think the amendment says
amend the bill by replacing section one
so section one
the old bill is gone and that language
therefore is gone isn't it
and
i'm sorry i've gotten confused in my
screens here but
um
can you hear me
yes okay
i am going to have to eat humble pie and
um
say that i was reading the part of the
amendments that said inserting after
section one the following new section so
i was reading line four as being uh the
beginning of the bill so i am going to
apologize for that and
just say that um
you know
not knowing when things are coming up
i ought to have been more prepared
but
thank you representative we've all been
there and douglas will be there many
more times
anybody else with a hand up on the bill
representative
shapiro you mr chairman i am um
comforted by many of the
many aspects of the amendment
especially
um
regarding
vaccinations in schools um which my
understanding is that will remain
exactly as it is with an exception
um
with the cooperation of a physician or a
medical practitioner so i am comforted
by many of the things um
in the amendment
right now
a nursing home does not really have the
ability to um
[Music]
to mandate that all its employees
get vaccinated
and under this bill
um
that would that would still be the case
so nothing practical would change if my
understanding is correctly
but i am still concerned that you know
there's a little bit of a there's more
than a little bit there's a tug of war
between
group versus the rights of the
individual
and i am concerned that this kind of
further enshrines the rights of the
individual over the rights of the
um
of the group and in in the case of a
nursing home all the patients and other
employees who work there so
um
i am going to vote against
anyone else i think i see representative
kanark
yes just a follow-up to representative
shapiro we often hear that phrase that
we've heard for the last 12 months we're
all in this together i think that's kind
of what representative shapiro is
driving at
yes we do have individual rights we also
do have the rights to the group as a
whole and we are all in this together
and we have to sometimes
change a few things about our behavior
for the respect of others
uh
our fellow
our fellow citizens or in the case of
employment
our patients that we're looking after
that we have to make sure we don't make
them sick
so i also think that the amendment makes
it markedly better but i still oppose
the bill thank you
representative marsh
thank you for my fellow representatives
and especially representative shapiro i
i i think that
we truly need to be concerned as to
whether we are protecting patients in
nursing homes and hospitals particularly
considering the number of patients
who've died in nursing homes uh from
covet 19 in the current epidemic i i
think that the number of deaths that
have occurred in nursing homes in this
current pandemic is more than sufficient
uh to
make the case that failing to be
vaccinated in that specific instance
would constitute a direct threat so i
believe that the language as we now have
before us would cover that eventuality
and and allow nursing homes to protect
their residents and for that reason i
intend to support this this bill is
amended
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman
i also concur with representativero that
the fundamental issue that i see is the
group versus the individual
the amendment the way it's written does
allow for the employer to make that
determination based upon an individual
situation
that the benefits of the group outweigh
the benefits of the individual
so even though
we're leaving it open to uh
interpretation i think it comes down to
allowing the employer to make that
determination is to benefit the group
does outweigh in fact the benefit to the
individual and therefore they can still
mandate under the federal law
requirement
final chance before we vote
seeing representative cushman stand up
thank you mr chairman
um members of the committee i urge you
to
vote the support of this bill
um
you know we're having this philosophical
difference here about uh individualism
versus collectivism
and i just want to remind everybody that
this is the united states of america and
the individual rights are protected by
the constitution
and
enshrined in nursing codes of ethics
also in provision one
the the right of bodily autonomy
and self-determination is outlined as
being
imperative it is of utmost importance in
care
this is a principle that
is threaded throughout our society and
throughout our history and we need to
ensure that people have that right
you know
it's not
i don't believe that it's the
responsibility of you know if someone
sees that
a risk with a vaccine they shouldn't
have to potentially set themselves on
fire to keep others warm this is a way
i've heard it phrased before you know
it's
it this is an individual decision
people's health
that's a balance of benefit versus risk
to an intervention
and no one should be
um you know
on a second tier in society because they
make a decision about their health that
other people don't agree with they're
individuals and they have a right to
make decisions over their bodies thank
you
i see representative i think i say
i will try to be extraordinarily brief
i'm also going to vote against this bill
although i do like the
some attempts that the amendment has
made to correct it
i guess when we talk about bodily
integrity that's one thing but
when we talk about integrity from having
to wear masks or socially distance etc
that i have the right to refuse to do
that even though i know full well that
it endangers people around me i do not
want to give any individual the right to
make that claim and put my health in the
health of other people that i care about
at risk so i'm going to vote against the
bill although i will vote for the
amendment because i think
at least that's a qualified attempt to
improve what i consider to be a bad bill
to start with
thank you representative weber
thank you mr chairman i'm i'm a little
confused i think we've already have we
not already voted the amendment we have
heard the amendment we're not voting the
bill and i
i would like to say that
you know having completely mis
missed a small piece uh but an important
small piece of the amendment
and knowing that we're over time
i would very much appreciate it if we
could recess the executive session and
until the next time we meet on this bill
because i have been arguing very
fiercely against it
on the basis of having the no person may
discriminate language which has now been
removed
and i'd like a chance to just think
about it a little more
and i want to be sure also that i have
not
been
sort of
to the extent that i can influence
anybody on this committee and and heaven
knows you're all very very strong people
uh i want to be sure that i have not
been raising red flags for people which
have actually been addressed and i can't
really make that determination this
quickly and i'm sorry not to have
gotten hold of the right end of the
stick earlier but i wonder if we might
just have a little more time on this one
let me put this to representative marsh
as the sponsor of the now amended bill
would you like us to come back to this
representative or are you ready to roll
well that's two separate questions
personally i'm ready to roll but i don't
think representative weber's ready to
roll and this committee usually works
fairly cooperatively and she's made
accommodations for me in the past and
i'm i'm okay this is the deadline for
this is not tomorrow so i'm i'm willing
to let it go until the next time we
exact bills if
that's your pleasure pervasive on many
occasions
all right is that is that a hand surgeon
demonstrating his crafter does he wish
to be recognized representative woods
uh uh thank you i'm going to expose my
um perhaps confusion
but i need uh clarification
um
the amendment that we addressed i
thought
i understood
but could you clarify exactly the number
of the amendment that we talked about
0 3 3 4 h that's exactly what i thought
might i add
and this was to a comment made by
representative weber
that section one still stands an
amendment states it says
by inserting after
section one
so section one in the original bill
no if i may mr chair yes
uh no i i neglected to read line one i
believe you're reading
line
three and you just took the same wrong
turn that i took to begin with
line one says amend the bill by
replacing section one with the following
so the language of the original bill
that has the
this is this is why i'd really like a
little more time basically to get this
sort of i see where you're i i just i
didn't read i didn't
did not read line one
we're going to move on because one
good question leads to another and i'm
going to take the suggestion that we
will look at this and continue the
executive session from where we left off
we don't revoke the amendment that's
been voted in if representative marsh
wishes to do anything or anybody else
wishes to bring an amendment they have
the right to do that we will not be
picking this up
until at least we meet again if not
later
and the chair calls on the clerk for
probably a
procedural question
you guessed that one um in uh for past
clerks
do i
um begin an executive session report
turn it in and then later do a
supplement
since we did vote on the amendment today
i would defer to um
my predecessor for wisdom on that and i
didn't even bring
masons with me uh
i mean i i can ask i can i can contact
paul smith
i would ask hcs frankly okay
my own thought would be hold it until we
have the entire executive session
completed
they may want it done differently so
okay
i'll double check with them thank you
very much
but i'd hold on to it until we got all
the way done
executive session is in recess and now
the chair opens a
i mean
what it is a discussion a hearing that's
it on um
house bill 605
and we start with an amendment
on that
h
an amendment to 605.
um
i'm totally yeah we have to hear the
bill first
you need to have somebody introduce the
bill that is that is where my mind was
limping towards
so right
right
605 f and representative conley your
bill
mr chairman committee members are you
able to hear me yes sir okay excellent
uh well thank you uh for the opportunity
to come before you today i am
casey connolly state representative from
dover stratfor county district 13.
and i am here to introduce hb 605.
this bill contains a number of
enhancements to the new hampshire
therapeutic cannabis statute some of
which the house has heard before
and some of which this committee has
heard before in separate measures
but i will highlight a few key aspects
of this bill um
now one is uh it would allow for home
cultivation of cannabis for people who
are designated caregivers that's
something not allowed under statute
[Music]
bill sets guidelines and restrictions
for how this would be done
um
and it also provides an avenue for
people who who use this medicine to to
get it at a more affordable price we
know cost
is a recurring concern
for therapeutic cannabis patients
and this could presumably help with that
um it also sort of brings new
hampshire's standards uh for therapy
cannabis more in line with surrounding
states
um
it adds two new qualifying conditions
one for moderate and severe insomnia the
other for opioid misuse disorder
um
it will allow therapeutic cannabis
patients to be certified for up to three
years instead of every year
it would allow people from other states
who are qualified and certified in the
places they live for therapeutic
cannabis to access their medicine within
new hampshire
therefore you know eliminating issues
around transporting the medicine across
state lines and just ensures that they
can have access to it while they're
visiting our state or working here or
whatever brings them here
and finally there are just a number of
other housekeeping
[Music]
points uh included in this bill
so although i am the prime sponsor uh
the work done on this bill was done by
the uh democratic leader representative
rennie cushing this is really his work
i fully support these changes of course
and i'm happy to sponsor the bill he is
um
uh intending to testify today um so i'm
happy to take questions i'm also happy
to uh seed the floor uh to him and to
others who would be better prepared to
answer questions the committee might
have but with that i will certainly do
the chair next we'll call representative
can you hear me
again
okay
uh thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record i'm
representing randy cushing from
rockingham district 21 and i'm here in
support of this bill
when the legislature kind of went into
hibernation last year
there were a number of pieces of
legislation that had passed both the
house and the senate that related to our
therapeutic cannabis program
and uh what i did
in the
in the early uh spring late spring and
early summer was to cobble bills that
had been passed by the house
um
primarily through this committee and
bills that have been passed through the
senate uh that related a therapeutic
cannabis and put them together and and i
tried to bring them
forward to the senate in the hopes that
it might make the cut uh as
a one of the um omnibus bills that the
senate uh put before us uh unfortunately
i was told that there would be no
bills that had the word cannabis in them
that would make it to the level of being
able to be an omnibus bill
so what you have before you is uh
essentially that that would be
uh
omnibus bill uh that that we bring in
now and upset what the bill contains are
includes senate bill 548 from last year
and senate bill 703 from last year
those were both passed by the senate
unanimously on their way both of those
bills were requested by the department
of health and human service by the
therapeutic cannabis program and it's
incorporated and one of the simple
protections for uh you know employees of
health and human services for
transporting you know materials that
would be otherwise prescribed but doing
so as part of their job for working with
the therapeutic cannabis program um and
the other uh
was a uh you know making some changes
relative to the
registry identification card again
simple just simple uh the matters that
the
the agency thought would be appropriate
and did um
so then it also included house bill 366
which added opioid misuse and abuse to
the qualifying conditions
and house bill 461
which added insomnia to qualifying
medical conditions
it also uh included house bill 1150
which permitted qualified patients
visiting from the out of state to access
new hampshire therapeutic cannabis
dependent dispensaries you know right
now uh
maine you know some states recognize uh
a reciprocity if someone has a is a
therapeutic cannabis patient here in new
hampshire they go to maine on vacation
or go to school uh their their card
there is recognized and they can use it
in a dispensary uh right now new
hampshire does not have a similar
reciprocity uh system so that was a
pretty straightforward uh request um and
and the last two are house bill 1356
which repealed the therapeutic use of
cannabis advisory board in house bill
1591 relative to cannabis use during
pregnancy both of which as you know
passed the the house and i believe that
they are before you as um a
as new bill's separate bills this um
session um but anyhow that's what that's
basically what's included in house bill
605 i wanted to know where it came from
i wanted to um you know
mr leader will you take questions
absolutely mr chair anybody for mr
leader
thank you
mr chairman and thank you mr leader for
taking my question
um
it appears that we have actually already
exact several provisions that may be
either included or similar to provisions
that are in
this bill
would you be okay if somebody on the
committee took out
knowing the senate's
dislike of omnibus bills not created by
them
um
would you be okay if if committee
members took out the pieces that we've
acted on separately already and simply
left the other bits
of the bill
you know of course
i you know what like i'm gonna steal it
again as i said i recognized
that uh you know when this bill was
written and submitted i had no idea
which individual component what other
bills would be out there that would
relate to this i know that you've passed
legislation and if that makes sense go
ahead and do it please
thank you
any other questions for the democratic
leader
i think representative acton wants to
ask me a question
okay representative acton
okay uh thank you mr chair and uh thank
you mr leader um
would you believe that it was probably
me who should have communicated with you
and cleaned this up before it got to
this point but it happened at a time i
was extremely busy and it slipped
through the cracks like earlier this
morning um representative acton i i
always appreciate
your leadership on this issue and i
always enjoy collaborating with you on
uh trying to improve our therapeutic
cannabis program i'm not sure
sure that
you know things happen it's a busy time
so however it is that the that you and
your committee feel uh would be best to
proceed i'm supportive of that
thank you and i will be available for uh
representative folsom
uh thank you mr chair and thank you uh
representative cushing um
my question is having to do the first
portion
where it protects employees of the
department of health and human services
funds possessing the transporting
um
do they have protections for if they're
in possession for transporting any other
kinds of uh um
medications that would
otherwise be illegal to transport
without a prescription
i believe that this was said you know
this would recognize that there are
exemptions for we do we make exemptions
under under the therapeutic cannabis law
for uh use for possession
of uh substances that otherwise are
prohibited and this would be ensure that
um
that an employee of dhhs who in the
process of you know transporting this
doesn't isn't held liable for it i think
it's kind of i can't anticipate anyone
actually being prosecuted for doing
my hand is not raised
sorry
my hand is not up but thank you for
recognizing me
so i can recognize you all from about 30
feet now
then uh thank you mr leader and we all
stand with you at this time sir
the chair recognizes uh representative
kenner
thank you very much um and again for the
record representative jerry kirk
representing carroll county dis uh
district three and uh
i'm here again today in my capacity as
the chair of the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board
um i sent everybody written testimony a
lot of it is redundant with what we said
before but i wanted it in the record for
this particular bill um so i will be
kind of glossing over things because
again this is a bill that certainly has
a lot of different parts to it and the
part that i'm going to primarily
concentrate on then is the part about
opioid use disorder
if you look at hb 605 page 1 lines 22 to
that adds opioid use disorder as a
qualifying condition
yet as organisms stated this language
stems from a 2019 retained bill hb 366
which sought to add opius opioid use
disorder oud as a qualifying condition
tcmob did consider this condition in
detail with a preliminary discussion
hearing and really a couple of different
meetings where we had rather robust uh
heated discussions about it and the
point is that the question of using
therapeutic cannabis and oud is
complicated
first it's important to understand and
this is really critical the cannabis
does have benefit in treating chronic
pain either replacing an opioid or
decreasing the required dose of an
opioid for a patient to have sufficient
relief
but that fact does not prove that
cannabis can successfully treat oud
because oud is different than chronic
pain it is an addiction with craving and
life disruption so very different so we
can't make an automatic assumption
pointless cannabis has a lot of uh
bioactive cannabinoids and terpenes that
all have different physiologic effects
thc
the psychoactive component that causes
euphoria and this is the tricky part it
stimulates the reward system and
therefore it does have addictive
properties
which is what can lead to cannabis use
disorder directly and the increased rate
of oud in people who have chronic
cannabis use and that may be
counterproductive in treating oud now
cbd can be very helpful in reducing
anxiety and craving in the early
abstinence from opioids
so it may have a role in treating oud by
reducing the risk of relapse so in 2019
we worked really hard to try to develop
some compromised language to
allow oud as a qualifying condition but
again with some rather strict parameters
the parameters being that we certified
only by a clinician waivered to provide
medication-assisted treatment for oud
or a certified addiction medicine or
addition addiction psychiatry physician
and would be used to treat the cravings
or the withdrawal
and we it's important to understand that
the certifying provider does have the
authority to require that the atc would
provide a cbd dominant therapeutic
cannabis if that's what they desired
ultimately the boat the board voted to
not approve oud as a qualifying
condition but the decision was quite
split it was four to six
and so
we brought i brought that recommendation
back to hhsea and the um
in the
fall of 19 and then it came through to
us uh to vote on later in the early part
of 2020. um and the
committee hhsea did vote to still
approve oud they felt that
you know they got kind of mixed guidance
from tcmob
and felt it was reasonable enough to
still put it in again it passed the
house but died in the table in the
senate
now i brought it back to the to the
board we decided not to formally revote
on it but we did actually even work on
the language a little bit further
implying that you know again we
understand that this isn't a cut and
dried uh decision
so we clarified one other thing which
will need to be added to this if we go
forward with this we wanted to clarify
that that waivered physician has to be
the physician that's providing the mat
for that individual patient not just any
random person that does mat but the
person who cares for the patient who's
being certified
and in my written testimony i do have
that language and the that phrase that
needs to be added for the individual
patient
the section on insomnia we've already
talked about that that's in
hb 89 we've already passed that this
morning i won't go any further on that
um the autism spectrum disorder i was
going to bring forward again the request
to add that as an amendment here if
desired but again we've already added
that to
sb-80 sorry hb 89 so it's probably not
necessary to consider that for this bill
depending on whether strategy wise we
think it's better to have an
omnibus bill or not but given what we've
just said the other side of the wall
doesn't always like an omnibus bill they
didn't write so it's probably better to
let that be freestanding the pregnancy
and cannabis use i would say again hb
163 which we're voting on in a couple of
days
does an even better job than in this
bill it's more robust and includes that
education about cannabis use and
adolescence so that could certainly be
amended out so the bottom line is large
portions of this bill can be amended out
and the oud though is still i think
somewhat of a
controversial question but with the uh
rather strict
criteria that the tcmob came up with
um i think they will be at least
understanding if this gets passed they
weren't adamantly against it by any
means i would also just want to quickly
comment on that issue about that first
section it is just clarifying some
language about the
the immunity for the alternative
treatment center it has it just simply
adds because the original language just
said if they're giving this information
to qualifying patients but we know that
a lot of patients have designated
caregivers and it allows it to be able
to be dealing with designated care
caregivers and visiting qualifying
patients so it really is just a
technical correction um that's really
all i have and basically again in
summary
oud is reasonable to consider with a
mixed feeling from the
board and uh the other things we've
really kind of taken care of and the
other some of the issues which have to
do with much more mechanical and not
medical i'm going to defer to michael
thank you chairman um thank you
representative
um
i'd like to uh piggyback onto something
representative weber said earlier about
the senate and omnibus bills
um when i look at section uh the first
point in the analysis
looks like
just a cleanup kind of legal issue
the other is the oud
which is a more complex medical issue
um
the permit out of state residents
almost seems like a commerce type issue
would it now be better for all of us and
our brains and handing this over to the
personally i think that would have been
better i i'm not i know omnibus bills
can be more efficient in some senses but
you're right when we're dealing with
medical questions and we're linking them
together with uh
correcting language and linking together
with some extensions and changes i think
it can make it difficult to pass which
is why i think for example uh the
insomnia and asd are better to just stay
in 89 because that's a clean bill
without a lot of other
baggage that might bring down
that the passage of those qualifying
conditions so i wish it were the case um
i don't know if we can
divide the bill or not i'm not sure if
that's our capability but a lot of it
can just be amended out
and i know that we have an amendment
that has been sent out by representative
marsh i think it might have end out too
much because it leaves out the
qualifying condition
condition of oud if i remember right but
follow up
uh yes thank you
um this uh i'm not quite sure
mr chair who i should address this to
uh he brought uh representative knick
brought up the question of whether or
not going to be broken out into separate
bills so this might be your question or
representative weber's question
um
how far is where
should we even look at that
my experience and knowledge i don't
think we can't break this bill up in a
number of places and send them to one of
the committees that should be
sailed but uh okay thank you
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative knurk for taking this
question first i'd like to just like to
add that the um
cannabis cultivation bill also was exact
and um yeah voted ought to pass in this
committee too so that is another one
that could be
edited out of this bill
my question really revolves around um
all the specific considerations in the
oud bill
um you know
specific kinds of
providers
specific kinds of products at the atc
this would also apply to the autism
spectrum
disorder
amendment that we looked at before
and um i'm asking this in naivete i just
don't know how it works well enough and
um
it seems like most of the qualifying
conditions earlier on were just black or
white you got qualified or you didn't so
i'm wondering how onerous these specific
considerations are for
patients practitioners the atc's to
actually keep track of and
[Music]
you know
use the specific considerations it seems
like a lot more it seems a lot more
complicated but maybe it isn't so you're
the one to ask
well here's the issue remember
in the beginning
it was a bunch of legislators that
passed this based on testimony we didn't
do the kind of deep dive that tcmob does
and you those of you our providers know
just how much time a lot of providers
can spend really
digging deep and into all the details
about treatment and what's the best way
to do something i mean if we read any
clinical guidelines you know that
they're really long and a lot of
information in them because it is always
really straightforward we this is an
intentionally high barrier because again
it is not something where everybody with
oud ought to just start taking
therapeutic cannabis because we don't
want to cause harms
by too much thc which may be
counterproductive so the goal was to
have somebody who knows what they're
doing so somebody who treats addiction
or medical medication assisted treatment
and with really dealing with the
cravings and withdrawal is the primary
thing
so with all that in mind
this is one where it is so dicey now it
may be that when we go back and revisit
some of those other older qualifying
conditions we may add some more
conditions would it be burdensome
yes and no i mean it means that the the
patient simply can't go to their pcp and
say hey doc i want to try therapeutic
cannabis because i've been really having
a lot of problems for the last three
years with my heroin addiction
uh probably a primary care doc shouldn't
be doing that but if they are waivered
to do medication assisted treatment or
they're an addiction psychiatrist they
would have the quality understanding as
to how this all works and we have these
kind of people on the board which is
what makes this such a robust discussion
for the
for for that provider if you ask your
person who's already taking you through
on your suboxone therapy or something
like that they'll be aware of this and
they can just say you know either yes or
no as far as the department michael holt
will have to answer that but i would
presume it's not overly burdensome
because they would just have a they
would just look at the credentials of
the person who sent in the certification
but it does add probably a little
complexity but these are bars that we
set intentionally to make it more
difficult because we don't have the kind
of straightforward fda approval because
it's a schedule one drug
follow-up
oh yes sir
yes um maybe you've already said this
but i understand the clinical
considerations completely and i think
you've done an incredibly thorough job
um
so it's really just the practicality you
know if we make it clinically sound but
then too complicated to use it kind of
defeats the purpose so i would look
forward to hearing from mr holt about
um
how smooth he feels that this could be
accommodated
right and the other thing that is
interesting is again this is when the
great virtues of having a patient
representative we're currently
on our meeting in a week and a half
we're going to be hashing through sb 29
which is a
another bill and one and one of the
things that we are really troubled with
is does it set up too many barriers
uh for people uh because it has a limit
on the on the um
on the strength of thc that would be
available in a dispensary for somebody
who's under age 21. and the question is
you know we agree with the medical
concept but same with thing you're
saying is it too much of a barrier so we
do take that into account and that's
where that patient representative and
the at representatives really help us a
lot because they did not have too many
they didn't have any difficulties with
this particular issue um on on this one
but it is it is something we do take
anyone else for representative canark
seeing no one but then the jerk calls on
uh hello mr chair members of the
committee can you hear me
sir
thank you very much my name is michael
holt i'm the administrator of the
therapeutic cannabis program thanks for
the opportunity to provide information
about house bill 605
um
the
so um so yeah i'm happy to happy to
answer these questions that have come up
and i'm happy to provide some a little
bit of clarity on the framework here so
uh to to echo uh representative cushing
this bill is all of the bills from last
session that passed at least one uh
chamber of the legislature and uh was
tabled by the other
chamber so this is an omnibus bill from
every piece of legislation tcp
legislation that passed at least one
chamber from last year
there are a total of eight provisions in
in this bill um seven of which are
listed on page one the analysis section
um
of those eight total provisions
two the first two are part of the
department requested omnibus bill which
is currently in uh the senate senate
bill 162.
four of the remaining ones have been
have standalone bills that this
committee has already exect on
there are two provisions left of which
this bill is the only
vehicle for consideration
on the analysis section those would be
parts three and part five part three
would add opiate opioid use disorder and
part five would permit out-of-state
residents to access
the new hampshire atcs
so
in terms of an amendment that would
pair this bill down
to be not redundant with anything else
in this session uh the the sections
related to parts three and part five
would be maintained and everything else
could be eliminated
and i'm happy to walk through anyone who
the the the representative who will be
preparing an amendment to deal with uh
the clean up of this bill um to make
sure we get uh all the eyes dotted and
the t's crossed
so with that i would ask the chair if
if that is the intent or the likely
intent um
we can talk about the two provisions of
this bill that are part of the
department's omnibus bill in the senate
which is the protections for tcp
department staff to possess cannabis for
regulatory purposes and also section two
or part two which um is a cleanup based
on an uh performance audit um by the lba
from 2019
so i'm happy to go through these uh
these sections of the bill that are
redundant with our bill um in the senate
uh that we would support that we do
support department requested um if
that's the best use of uh the
committee's time
um
[Music]
i would pause there to say how much how
much do you want to hear from me about
uh this bill based on a potential
amendment coming along down the pike mr
holt let me throw this out and i can see
dramatic gestures
does this sound good to the committee
that what we hear going forward is about
those parts which are likely to be
removed by amendment as unnecessary
we've already done them and so to save
time we just hear about the parts that
potentially we could
keep
okay and if it's not good to you make a
and if you're not sure diagonal
okay somebody fell out of a chair on
that sorry um yes mr hall please go on
on the parts that uh
we're likely to keep
okay very good so um the two again to
reiterate there's two sections of the
bill um that will be coming over from
the senate as part of our omnibus bill
that which we support would be uh parts
one and two um audit related information
uh to increase the uh the the duration
of a certification for up to three years
and also to allow department staff to
possess cannabis for regulatory purposes
so those are the provisions that will
come over we'll hear those when it comes
over from the senate
representative knurk has done a an
excellent job introducing the section of
the bill um that would add opiate opioid
use disorder uh the department doesn't
have a position on that the tcmob is
doing uh fine work um in this regard uh
the only other provision that i would
like to speak about and again this is a
provision that does not uh the
department does not have a position on
um however my testimony will establish
that it it is a value and the the the
legislature should consider it or it
can't consider it and that is
the provision it's listed as number five
on the analysis section um
permits visiting qualifying patients
basically
patients who have
medical marijuana cards from a different
state
the opportunity to access new
hampshire's alternative treatment
centers
um so this is the this is the main
policy provision proposal here um
currently under state law we have what i
would call limited reciprocity what that
means is that the current law allows
out-of-state cardholders
to legally possess cannabis in the state
of new hampshire they're afforded the
same protections
from arrest and prosecution for
possessing cannabis in accordance with
our state law
as
new hampshire residents do
however
they are not permitted by state law to
purchase
cannabis in new hampshire
or acquire cannabis through any means
legally in new hampshire from either a
patient or a caregiver in new hampshire
what this means is that we allow
visiting qualifying patients the
opportunity to legally possess it here
but we are encouraging them to break an
additional federal law by carrying it
across state borders
so what this bill would do
would allow those visiting qualifying
patients to access the atcs here
purchase cannabis products here so that
they don't run afoul
the the federal prohibition of crossing
state lines with therapeutic cannabis
in addition this provision of the bill
would also clarify the law
um for the purposes of law enforcement
right now current law affords this
protection to out-of-state patients only
if they have a qualifying medical
condition that is recognized by new
hampshire state law
so for example a common condition
for therapeutic cannabis throughout new
england
is anxiety
new hampshire does not permit
patients with anxiety to possess
cannabis
what this means is that someone from
massachusetts who has a medical
marijuana card issued in that state for
the condition of anxiety when they cross
over the border
do not enjoy the legal protections
because new hampshire does not permit
anxiety
as a qualifying condition here in the
state what that means is that law
enforcement personnel um in in the field
at a traffic stop would need to
uh
have internalized and know all the
qualifying conditions here in this uh in
the state
know that
a
an out-of-state patient may have a
different qualifying condition
require that out-of-state patient to
also produce a letter from their medical
provider that states that qualifying
condition match them up all the side of
the road during a traffic stop um so
this this proposal would have the the
the effect of simplifying the process
and grant um a broad uh recognition of
out-of-state medical marijuana cards
um
so those are those are the
those are the aspects of this provision
of the bill that i would ask the
legislature to consider
thank you mister
well before i call on someone to ask you
a question we
welcome representative soloway back into
the meeting
and the chair recognizes representative
weber for a question
thank you and i will note that
representative salloway is actually
visible he was just muted when he
replied
um and i'm hoping i am now unmuted uh
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
holt for taking my question my question
is just one of drafting uh with respect
to
the analysis sections one and two which
you said are in a bill coming towards us
from the uh senate
the
is the senate bill exactly like ours or
somewhat different and do you think we
should
uh keep those two in just as
belt and suspenders or do you think they
should be taken out entirely if indeed
you have an opinion if you don't want to
give an opinion that's okay too
uh thank you representative weber i
appreciate the allowance to not have an
opinion uh
um however um i i can say that both of
those provisions are an exact carbon
copy of um of
what's coming over in the senate
um and i do not have a preference on
whether or not they should be maintained
here i fully expect
our omnibus bill to uh to pass the
senate with those provisions intact
okay thank you very much that's very
helpful i appreciate it
thank you for your testimony
uh mr chair i would like to address uh
representative shapiro's question about
the department's ability to administer a
if i may yes
uh thank you uh so representative
shapiro um the the departments
recognizes that it does create a
different standard it's not just a yes
no check box um it will require uh some
work on our part to verify
um that the providers who are certifying
for that particular condition
are in fact um uh have have certified
specialties in those uh in in those
fields but that's not something that i
see as an administrative uh really
burdensome task it will add some uh some
responsibilities but it's something that
the chair now recognizes
mr michael mclaughlin to come back
from sanctuary alternative treatment
center
excuse me mr chairman but representative
salloway had his hand up and i believe
it was for a question from mr holt i am
sorry my friend
question away
representative sullivan
after you're unmuting
okay
thank you mr chairman
mr holt are you are you there
i am thank you oh it's i've i always
enjoy your testimony i learned from you
so i have a question
were the fda
to uh
drop the current categorization of
uh
that is a million dollar or
multi-million dollar question facing the
entire country at this point um
uh and it's speculative um
depending on what the federal government
did with the federal legalization of
cannabis um whether they they have
options of whether to to deschedule
entirely uh which means it's tobacco
like a tobacco product or they could
reschedule it as a different schedule uh
um a drug
um would depend would would determine
what impact that has
on state legal therapeutic cannabis
programs
one of the thoughts in the federal
government is to
simply remove barriers for states to
implement
cannabis laws on their own and not have
a federal uh policy um so it's it really
is speculative up in the air and um with
the new federal administration you know
we may see some some action over the
next four years um that we have not seen
in the past so to be continued i'm sure
thank you mr hope
welcome
wow
i see no one else
with a hand up either yellow or
otherwise so i will now call on
mr michael mclaughlin from sanctuary
alternative treatment center
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee i'm going to say that
traditional can you hear me now voice
no yes
no
some of us can't just enough to know how
to answer that
you're not muted but you're very um it's
hard to hear
okay are we better now
yes okay uh again my name is michael
mclaughlin i'm a lawyer and lobbyist in
the country of new hampshire i represent
sanctuary atc
and we are very much in favor of the
provision in
hospital 605 to allow out-of-state
patients with
legitimate cards from their states to
access new hampshire atc's i would
remind the committee that last year
house bill 1150
was heard by the committee and the
committee voted
to or ought to pass on that bill and we
sent it over to the senate where it as
people mentioned earlier it did die on
the table
the
opportunity to provide service to
out-of-state patients with qualifying id
cards is helpful in many ways to enhance
your agencies
we have atcs that are located close to
the borders of maine and to vermont one
in keene one in dover one in
conway
and the opportunity to be able to
provide quality therapeutic cannabis to
both people from out of state who are
near new hampshire and to transits and
tourists who come to new hampshire
to experience new hampshire experience
is very helpful
again as michael hope mentioned it's
also great to be able to
[Music]
relieve law enforcement of any confusion
on who may uh have the benefits of new
hampshire law so uh again we've been
much in favor of leaving the out of
state um provisions in house bill 605
and would only remind the committee that
we had a very good discussion of last
year it's a
something the department is put together
and will help us enforce and i think it
works for new hampshire thank you
seeing none of the chair calls on mr
hello can you hear me
yeah
hi how are you today all right thank you
how are you good i'm doing great thanks
again for having me back i'm dr david
sarick
medical director for sanctuary atc i did
speak earlier
in favor of house bill 89 which also
adds insomnia
to the qualifying medical conditions to
the new hampshire tc law so
we do support that in this bill as well
and see and we also uh strongly support
adding the opiate use disorder to the
qualifying meta conditions as well
and
as mr mclaughlin just stated too
sanctuary atc also supports out-of-state
medical cannabis
patients access to our dispensaries here
in new hampshire
and i in my opinion this really should
have been allowed from the inception of
the program and for those of you who are
out there that particularly um are
opposed to this bill don't really know
how sort of embarrassing is when a
patient from a different state comes
with a legal cannabis card
and basically has to be turned away at
the door by us it's pretty embarrassing
so
you know um
allowing patients access
in a different state with a card you
know obviously will prevent this and
actually you know
make new hampshire
appeal a little less
uncompassionate basically
um
also
allowing um
i'm not sure was the pregnancy a part of
yeah i'm sure the pregnant like allowing
patients education and pregnancy we
obviously support that by really having
available pamphlets of brochures at the
dispensary
other than that i think we're pretty
thank you doctor for your testimony does
seeing none thank you dr cyrek thank you
is there anyone else who has signed up
any co-hosts have anybody in their
sights
it looks like everyone has spoken that
was signed up
well thank you it seems to me that uh
there's quite possibly
an amendment
coming taking out certain redundant
things and so therefore we will sit on
this for a week or so
so we we now
close the hearing on house bill 605
and
we will go into executive session
on house bill 2 21.
making the state vaccine registry an
opt-in program
i
have no amendments in front of me did
anyone bring forth an amendment that
somehow i have missed i need to look at
next
so
no one sees any so i guess
we're all in this together if we're
wrong
uh representative cushman would like to
make a motion i'd like to make a motion
to pass hb 221
as written
ought to pass not to pass representative
cushman do we have a second
and representative gay
has seconded it and
now we can have discussion
which can be in the form of a question
or in the form of a sentence
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman
as per my comments last week
i i don't like the idea of
state legislatures intervening
in the relationship between physicians
and patients
i also
absolutely value and cherish the right
of citizens to choose their own
participation
in medical decisions
however
we are on the verge of a viral
armageddon
i mentioned in my comments last week
that we would see another uh h in uh
avian influenza
about three days ago it was identified
as being here it is in russia now you
will see it here it is imperative
that we have decent data to be able to
track
who's immunized who's not immunized
who's at risk who's not at risk
though i'm not crazy about people having
to
opt in
as our role
i must speak
loud and clear against this we need to
build a public health infrastructure
it's imperative and there's no time to
waste thank you mr chairman
i'm sorry yes i
okay um we did hear a lot of testament
about the difficulties of having this be
an opt-in
and really what it amounts to is that
it is far too easy for people to neglect
opting into this
and
if a person really doesn't want to be in
it they have that choice to opt out
that's fine but to make it opt-in means
we're going to have a very poor
collection of data as representative
salloway was just commenting about but
it's we've heard about the difficulty
with communication and i don't know how
many of you have had this problem but i
know i've had a problem where i go into
my pcp and they ask about did i get uh
you know my flu shot and when did i get
it and i don't remember and yes i got it
over at the pharmacy but between the
fact that people get their injections at
providers at pharmacies or now even in
freestanding immunization clinics that
we have going on for covid
and that may occur again some other time
for other diseases as representative
soloway has alluded to the ability to be
able to know whether somebody's been
vaccinated or not is critical
particularly that whole issue of
preventing redundant vaccinations that
are really totally unnecessary a waste
of resources and might expose a patient
to more risk because they're getting
a um
immunization too early before that you
know
right after they've had another one so
for the communication
to be able to actually have things work
it's important if we look at the
countries like israel who have been able
to manage very good aggressive robust
vaccination programs a lot of that is
because they do have health records that
are interoperable i mean in our case you
know you go from a private practitioner
to your hospital and they can't even
talk to one another with an electronic
health record the ability to have
centralized databases for this kind of
information should be across the
healthcare spectrum i mean for example
in the va you're you're saying you live
in san francisco you hurt yourself in
boston you go in the va your va patient
they got access to your record they can
take care of you we can't do that across
our health care system for vaccinations
at least it's a good start to be able to
know who has been vaccinated and who
hasn't i don't mean for someone above to
know necessarily except maybe for data
acquisition for studies
but as far as your own internal
communication between your healthcare
providers and for your own peace of mind
to know what you've had
i do also remember
having to get my vaccination records
when i moved out to different areas and
trying to find out what i had for
pediatric vaccines and when i had them
it's very confusing so i think that this
is
a bad idea to make it opt-in because far
too many people will be compromised
without even knowing that they've
compromised their care because they did
not opt in if someone really wishes to
opt out that's fine but but do not make
it an opt-in
thank you
and representative woods
thank you mr chair
um i'm going to start at 30 000 feet
and then bring it down to 10 feet
um
when we talk about this uh we think of
two general themes one is
you know the the personal aspect of it
and the privacy issue etc
but our charge as a legislature is the
welfare
of our constituents of all new hampshire
uh folk
and it's been invoked uh article 2b
and i read it an individual's right to
live free from governmental intrusion
in private or personal information is
natural essential
and inherent
i understand that
however i read the next article
when men enter into a state of society
they surrender up
some of their natural rights to that
society
in order to ensure
the protection of others
and without such an equivalent the
surrender is void
so that's the balance we have to have
and our charge is to take care
of the granite staters
to do that we have to have good data
and we've been asking for good data
forever
when i served on
governor judd greg's commission in the
80s whatever it was one of the things we
came out of it was
this state has bad data
and we're still wrestling with it
but let me give you a 10 foot that's off
the 30 000 foot
if we don't have any data about well
example is school vaccinations
yep we have no idea
whether your kid or my kid or teacher or
anybody else
has measles mumps
whatever
okay
and so we have no way to advise we don't
have the data so we can't advise
the teachers the parents
we've got a cadre of folks here that
have never had measles they've never had
mumps vaccine
just because nobody's wanted it
turns out
no one's got it we don't know that
and so be careful what you ask for you
may get it because let's take for an
example mumps
we have no idea whether they've been
vaccinated or not
but all of a sudden there's a mumps
appear well voila
kid comes home and gives it to his
parents
well mumps specifically
and i don't know about the others but i
speak for my personal experience i had
mumps as a kid
and we know that when you bring it home
to your parents it can be devastating
my mother almost had to have a
tracheostomy because she had such a
violent reaction
on the male side if an adult male
gets mumps
it's very common that they become
sterile
so um
we have to be careful about what we wish
for because we just might get it
and what we get we might get is worse
so our charge i i
really plead
our charge is to take care of new
hampshire
with it
within reason and it's easy to opt out
and we understand that and that's
perfectly fine
but the opt-in we know
we know makes it very difficult we know
we don't get the data and therefore we
know we can't take care of new hampshire
folks and we know that there's going to
be consequences
so
i i really
encourage that we do not support an
thank you representative representative
marsh
yes thank you everyone uh
this is a difficult bill
and the reason it's a difficult bill is
because i don't like binary decisions
and this is a binary decision it's
either yes
or no
and i see very little way to amend the
bill to make it more acceptable to
everybody although if i were i would
remove the word written on line five i
and i think there is a great many points
about there being need for better data
there is we need better data
on the other hand
new hampshire has not had a functional
vaccine registry for some time
and i don't see that anything horrible
happened to the state of new hampshire
as a consequence of that i mean they did
have issues in other states
with some childhood diseases
but didn't happen in new hampshire
good that's possible we don't really
know
we have pretty high immunization rates
at this point in time
um so at the end of the day i think that
i will not vote uh
i i will support the passage of this
bill
but in some ways it's it's it's
reluctant um because i'd like to find
something that's more acceptable to
everybody
thank you mr chairman and thank you
my concern i have a couple of concerns
one is the lack of personal
responsibility aren't we capable of
having a card that we carry
and just encourage everybody carry your
card with you just like a driver's
license to keep a record of these uh
immunizations my other issue was that my
daughter
my kids had
all the shots that were recommended
as a 20 year old in college
she came down with a massive
uh infection of months
um
it didn't protect her
uh
so i agree it's very serious illness the
older you are
but just taking uh
just having a registry
which i assume encourages people to
take
to take vaccines
that doesn't make it happen and
i would think for our records
our statistical records
can't everybody just report that they
gave them out that they administered
them without a person's name being
attached
that feels like a violation of my
medical privacy
but i don't mind if i
if my data goes in
you know to a pool and just said we gave
out this many
of vaccines
thank you before we go to round two uh
anybody who has not
yet spoken in round one representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman
um i will support this bill
uh wholeheartedly
i believe that
and i know i mentioned it in my last um
our last executive session that informed
consent is paramount
when it comes to any
personal health matters
whether it's personal information or you
know taking an intervention
to
piggyback off of
representative gase point
you know
having a vaccine registry does not
going off of the article 3 of the
constitution
it says
without an equivalent
um the surrender of your rights is void
and you cannot guarantee that putting
your information in the backs of the
vaccine registry
you know
protects society as a whole
because vaccines are not a hundred
percent
we've seen this with mumps outbreaks in
vaccinated populations
you know
some vaccines like the covet vaccine
haven't been determined to even offer
protection to other people just the
received recipient
and
additionally
putting your information in this
database we shouldn't be tricking people
you know the arguments i'm hearing are
well it's easy it's it's too easy to
to
opt out if we require consent well that
implies that
you're setting up obstacles to go
against someone's
will on purpose to trick them into
obtaining their information
so i think that this bill just needs to
be passed and i would appreciate your
support on that thank you
representative
all right
thank you mr chair and um thank you
everyone for hearing me out
about a year ago
this time covert was on its way here we
knew it and we
saw what was going on in italy and it
was uh quite horrifying so i started
taking part in
online
ad hoc online groups to try to get more
information
and
some of the groups were were
run by epidemiologists and so forth
where we would actually be able to
discuss with what are the possibilities
of vaccines what are the
the different therapeutic treatments
for covid and it was a great resource
but
little by little
these these groups started getting deep
deep platform in and in essence censored
so what we did was we started creating
our own language uh coronavirus became
cerveza sickness because we didn't want
to trigger
the ai bots that that listen to what's
going on in a youtube video and then
delete the video if you talk about
certain things that aren't allowed and
what happened was
the world health organization viewpoint
became the only correct viewpoint and
any other conflicting information was
banned and and it was really
disconcerting to see
um these groups fall apart one after
another and and some moved to other
platforms other others just disappeared
and um so if you
i was in i was seeking good data
and i couldn't do it because we weren't
allowed to have good communication
and
so i'm i'm taking a hard hard line on on
these bills as much of a hard line as a
milktoast guide like me can can make i'm
taking a hard line on on the um
some of these because i think there
needs to be pushback
if i can't communicate
and if i'm shut out
of of
everything except
this
this global
organization then we don't have good
communication and we don't have good
data
so you know i'm like i said i'm not a
vaccine
extremist in any way i'm waiting to get
mine march 17th um but i i just um i'm
really concerned that the
at the
lack of
understanding for those of us who are
trying to find out more information
being shut down on the only way we can
communicate now which is social media so
my my little way of protesting is i'm
going to
take a hard line on on this bill here
and possibly some others as well thank
you
thank you representative representative
merchants
a couple of things one is i think the
patient has the ultimate
authority to opt out
they don't have to get the vaccine in
the first place
so if they want to protect
themselves from getting the vaccine on
the registry itself
i think it's simple enough just not
to receive the vaccine
the other issue i look at is i think
people are concerned about the data
going into a database
and a privacy connected to it let me
show you a story
i went into a
provider
the medical assistant was going over my
drug history
they said oh i see mr merchants you're
on this drug
a drug
the person i was saying the provider did
not prescribe for me
so i said how did you know i was on that
drug
i said oh it's in your claims data from
the insurance companies we buy it
so therefore they were getting all the
data for all their patients
through the drug
benefit program people
unbeknownst to me
so my privacy just went right out the
window
so as much as we're talking about
privacy here i just want to let people
know that in the new hampshire
department of insurance they have the
data
your pbm your drug plan has the data
your insurance company has the data so
if we're really concerned about privacy
of the data and protecting it this is
before we get to
round two
let and say a few things
i'm very conflicted on this i see both
sides of it and yet i can't split my
vote
in this very committee
last year or two
there was a bill asking for a very
randomized
collection of data it would be
randomized on abortion
and states across the political spectrum
from very red to very blue have this
data
and it was
shot down
interesting
i cheered two commissions on the deaf
the deafblind and the hard of hearing in
this state
this is on the other hand
and
there's so many things we'd like to plan
how many
such and such as do we need why do we
need to put that how about resources do
we need to train more individuals we
really wish we had data all we have is
some stories and we're not quite sure
how
that works in terms of reliable
actionable data and every time we turn
around there's no data
people are
not signing up or there's no place for
them to or they don't want to or they've
been told that if they signed up and let
somebody know they're hard of hearing
the government will be outside and you
know listen in on their conversations so
i mean i hear all of this stuff going
along um and i too wrestle with the
the confliction of individuals rights
and societal rights
and they're not separate things
you're in your or an individual
exercising his or her individual rights
sometimes is it my expense and i'm
losing individual rights
in that
other individual exercising too many
individual rights i just
i'm not quite sure what i'm going to do
except at the moment i'm very conflicted
thank you uh yes
point of order sir um yes uh
representative whoever had her hand up
and she wanted round one
whoa yes representative weber
uh this isn't round two talk is it is
this a point of order this is this no
this is i i haven't had a round one yet
you haven't no i i know you're shocked
at that but i haven't
um
one uncharacteristically
i invite you and thank you please to
great silence thank you very much and
thank you representative acton for
looking after my interests even though i
don't deserve it after my earlier
performance
i
here's the thing we're all grappling
with the balance of
individuals protection of their own
privacy which i think we're all for
and protecting society which i think
we're also all for and the question is
where do we split the balance there
and
for me this bill is an easy
easy cut to make
because if i care
and i don't want my information going in
a registry
i've already been given
the option to opt out when i signed the
thing before the pharmacist stuck
anything in my arm
i was told that i didn't have to go to a
registry
so if
i care about whether my information goes
in a registry i have absolute control to
keep it out
what we're talking about here is whether
the state should control for people who
don't care
whether they go in or whether they stay
out
and in that case i think the state
should not interfere i think that i i i
i would vote on the side of data
collection
and um
you know the the other bills that we had
did not have opt-out provisions
this has an absolute opt-out provision
for any individual
who cares
about opting out they may do so they
will not be compelled to get into this
registry
so why we put the default at being out
rather than in
i don't understand i see the opt out
registry
as the way of having it both ways
because if you don't care you stay in we
get the data and if we do care you've
got an absolute right to keep your data
out
so that's that's my analysis of the
thing and thank you very much
thank you
representative
mckay or properly makai
thank you mr chairman
the people we usually
respect in terms of their opinions about
medical conditions
all all oppose this legislation
dr daly from the department of health
and human services
the new hampshire hospital association
with paula minihan
dartmouth hitchcock hospital opposed
the new hampshire chapter of pediatrics
opposes
and two different physicians from the
new hampshire medical society oppose
this legislation i think that's very
important
information that we should pay attention
to
thank you sir
and representative cushman round two
thank you mr chairman
um so speaking to a couple of the points
that were raised um the patient does
have the ultimate authority to opt out
of receiving a vaccine yes and perhaps
medical data that's in the chart may be
bought and sold but this is
this is not we're not talking about
you know private health providers and
the vaccine registry is
um
you know this is a government
surveillance
and in violation of one of our
constitutional amendments uh
um and it it it doesn't just require
that every vaccination is reported in
the registry
the law currently requires even when
someone declines a vaccine that's a
vaccination event
so you can say that oh
you know
they can decline if they want to well
not unless they know that they can
decline to have it put have their
information put in there they decline a
vaccine and you don't tell them
or give them an opportunity to say
i don't want the fact that i declined
submitted to
the vaccine registry they're not going
to know so that's how it would be
tricking people into having their
information put in there
and we already know that this registry
will be used to target low vaccination
rate areas to increase vaccination
uptake and compliance and since the data
already includes who a person is
where they live
you know
what is to say that individuals will not
then be targeted if they don't know that
they can opt out and say no to a vaccine
you know we could see this as as
becoming um
quite a disagreeable
arrangement for a lot of people who just
want to be left alone to make decisions
over their bodies and keep their health
information private so just to avoid all
of that
everyone should be asked
if they want
their information in there whether it's
we asking to receiving a vaccine or
declining
it should be up to them thank you
thank you very much um
yeah i think actually it was it was
interesting because you sort of called
me and went to representative weber and
that was great because she made one of
the points i wanted to make and i think
that's important this is not an opt-in
versus mandatory it's opt-in versus
opt-out and that's what's so critical
and but representative webber covered
that well you do have the choice to opt
out if you care and i agree the default
should be to opt in and the reason i say
that again is not so much for massive
state data collection i'm really again
looking at it more from the patient
point of view representative gay said
well just keep your little card i got an
email
from somebody about this bill where they
were commenting about their their mother
with alzheimer's who had no clue what it
was that she had just had at the
pharmacy because again we have poor
communication back and forth uh
representative marsh made a comment
about
that we haven't had this and talking
about pediatrics but in pediatrics since
the vaccinations are given
uh in the pcp office they're not given
in the pharmacies except for flu at this
point
uh
that kind of communication is not a real
problem it's there the medical home
really needs to reside in the pcp office
where they know about what's going on
with that patient
and if they don't have the information
about what vaccinations that patient has
had it can be very tricky so we also
don't know how many
people have gotten redundant
vaccinations which are just a waste of
resources because they
didn't know when they showed up in their
pcp office
so i look at it more from the standpoint
of protecting the patient with regard to
being able to get good care
they don't know the importance of having
a vaccine registry so if they're asked
to opt in
they're not likely to necessarily say it
and not because they're worried about
their privacy they just don't understand
what this is all about but if somebody
really is worried about their privacy
they will know about it and they're the
one that can make that choice to opt out
as representative weber said so i still
think that it should be an opt
out program because it is far better to
make that
important
balance as representative salloway keeps
talking about between the individual and
the
the good of the society as a whole
the question before us house bill 2-2-1
making the state vaccine registry and
opt-in
program
the motion was bought to pass
moved by representative cushman seconded
by representative gay
would the clerk please unmute and call
that would probably help a little bit
sorry about that
um
thank you chairman pearson uh
representative marsh
yes
representative mcmahon
no
representative nelson
yes
got distracted on yes or no
do that in the middle of a voting mode
yes sorry
why don't you state it and
i'll have to rule on it
well
the question
of being voted on is ought to pass
if you agree with it you vote yes if you
disagree
that the um
no
okay no
right here
betty gay
yes
leah cushman
beth folsom yes
nikki kelsey
yes
bill king
jim cole fault
yes lucy webber
i'm sorry representative weber i'm
starting to use your spokesman either
way is fine i appreciate it and don't
vote why were you i just use the last
no
snow
yes he said no
but he should say it himself again
uh
maybe we can get his attention at the
end
uh knurk
what about snow
he's he's asleep
oh i'm sorry that was i thought you
would call him okay
cat
maybe someone can place a call to his
home i'll make a call yes thank you i'll
continue with the list
of my vote my vote
in the room so he can vote
he's awake about being asleep as a
disqualifier so make the call
um
he's awake now so
can you call rough snow again
yes
no representatives no we're voting on
um
uh whether the
plan should be
opt in or opt out
if you want the plan to be opt
in you will vote yes and if you want it
to be opt out you will vote no
all right you had to step away for a
moment yeah we're avoiding otp oh yes
he once had opt out so that would be a
yeah
no that's a no
representative snow when when i called
that the clerk could call the vote were
you in the room
i was in across the room yes i was in
the room
i was doing something else at that
moment
that that's legitimate and i wrote that
uh representative knuck
no
representative soloway no
representative cannon no
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro
no
woods
merchant
no
pearson
that is
i i hate to call it more trouble point
of order i believe i voted incorrectly i
wanted to vote yes to keep to make this
opt-in
i don't know if that's too late i would
hate to put us through emotions to be
considered the drop you may change your
votes
i would like to vote yes to make an
opt-in okay thank you
and now we've got a favorite of both
sorry charlie
i'd like to make an alternate motion i
recognize representative weber what is
your motion
my motion is an expedient to legislate
and that is
representative weber and um for the
benefit of our clerk
i prefer titles in this committee not
last names only okay i'm sorry um
[Music]
second second i i recognize uh
represent
dr solo
second
second yes
okay
okay now the motion before us is the
bill is inexpedient to legislate
moved by representative weber and
segmented by representative soloway
would the clerk please call
[Music]
representative marsh
yes
representative mcmahon
representative nelson
i'm sorry
yes or no
oh no
representative folsom no
representative kelsey now
representative kobalt
no
representative weber
yes
representative mccain yes
representative snow
yes
representative snerk
representative soloway yes
representative cannon
yes representative nutter upham
yes
representative shapiro
representative woods
yes
representative merchant
representative pearson
yes
and who would like to write the majority
report on 14
represent
that representative uh mr chairman
fine
and who would like to write the negative
i think we have time to squeeze one more
in
and this is bill 143 relative to an
electronic prescription drug program
and
we have been holding on to this bill
because representative merchant wished
to bring back an amendment to his own
bill so the chair recognizes
representative merchant first to speak
on your amendment thank you mr chairman
to my fellow
colleagues on the committee
143 has amendment and the amendment like
to speak to
his amendment
zero four four four h
dated
on february 18th
and what this amendment does
after a conversation with the hospice
community
and dealing with their concerns
they raised the issue about a compounded
medication
when you get into hospice therapy and
having worked as a hospice pharmacist in
the past
the challenges of trying to e-prescribe
a prescription with multiple ingredients
in it is difficult
in recognizing that
it made sense to amend the bill
to exempt that
i did look at the federal
sports act
and in the act it does allow for carving
out hospice patients
the other request they had
was not just the question about
temporary enough
interoperability of the technology
but also the access that a provider may
have with a hospice patient
so
those two
exempt exclusions were carved into the
amendment if you look at line
25 of the amendment
it says exactly that a compounded
medication a prescription
or a hospice patient would be exempt
as well if the provider
has temporary access issue not the
technology but access the technology
that would also be exempt
i did leave in the
exemption for the veterinarians written
in such a way
that their exempt until the time in
which the vet medical board determines
the software is widely available so they
are
100 in control of when the law kicks in
when they make that determination which
is on an annual basis they would notify
the border pharmacy at that point in
time the law would become effective
those are the changes i made within the
and i would ask you for oh sorry third
one
i got i just saw dr woods represented
woods
he also wanted clarification about the
licensing board because it wasn't clear
in the emit on the bill
that the waiver is given by the
respective licensing board overseeing
the licensee so if it's a medical
practitioner it's the medical board if
it's a dentist it's a dental board and
so forth
so that clarified that situation
provided clarity into the language of
the bill so that was the other
change that was done within the
representative merchant i have in my
notes a question asking on
item number six which is line 24 in the
mr chairman that is i think represent
brought that to our attention before
this will become inserted into the
statute once the bill goes through and
any questions for representative
the amendment number is zero four four
four h
mr chairman may i second the amendment
uh yes you may that's representative
march correct yes
yes
now we can
discuss
yes
anyone wish to
uh representative barge
yes i would just like to say that this
bill brings uh new hampshire and law in
line with federal law uh which is
currently uh
being
uh not enforced due to some
circumstances around the cove 19
pandemic
the
federal
requirement for
category 2 drugs to be done
electronically was put in place to
combat diversion and i think that's
entirely appropriate
and the two exemptions put in here by
amendment uh make the bill workable for
the veterinarians and for the hospice
patients and so therefore i support both
anyone else
if i may mr chairman
uh representative
thank you
thinking backing on to representative
martin's thing about the federal law
the date in which this becomes effective
is the same time in which the
cms is going to enforce if you will the
regulation for electronic prescribing
under part d which is again is generally
first 2022.
so that coincide with the federal law
we're not trying to impose something
at the state level before the federal
see no further discussion
the
matter before us is
moved by representative merchant second
by representative marsh as an amendment
to house bill 143
with the clerk please
call the roll
thank you mr chairman
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon
yes
representative nelson
yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king
yes representative
yes
representative weber
representative mckay yes
representative snow yes
representative knurk
yes
representative soloway
representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham
yes
representative shapiro
yes representative woods
yes
representative merchant
representative pearson
now that becomes part of the graph that
becomes part of the amended bill
will entertain a motion on house bill
143 as amended representative merchant
do you have a motion
i have a motion to make i'd make a
motion not to pass with amendment
a second
second
who is that please
representative marsh
i should know your
here
um thank you mr chairman
representative marsh
votes yes
representative mcmahon
yes representative nelson yes
representative acton
yes representative gay
yes representative cushman
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes
representative king
representative cofolt
now
representative weber yes
representative mckay
yes
representative snow
yes representative knurk
yes
representative soloway yes
representative cannon
yes
representative nutter upham
representative shapiro
representative woods yes
representative merchants
yes
representative pearson
it passes 21 to 2.
uh don't think so me
who would i miss
you're not 23 people there's not 23
people oh
sorry 19
it's it's been a long day folks it has
and over on the regular calendar
just a few little matters here uh
the two
bills that are sitting here in my
opinion
um um
excuse me
can i
represent uh the chairman can i know
well i'm thinking representative
merchant would like to write the plus
report and it's a toss-up between two
people to write the minority report and
either one of you or none of you may do
so
i can do that mr chairman thank you
okay thank you and thank you for the
point of order it's been a long day
all right just a few little housekeeping
items i would
um we we had a bill that we could have
executed but we are going to wait for
representative
to come back to us and see what we can
do with it the other two bills that
could be accepted right now are house
bill 572
which um has
uh
a
wobble big amendment that basically
changes everything i'm not sure we will
have time to do it in about 15 minutes
and ditto on house bill 157
so
since i know um
my colleagues from the other party uh
would like or some of them at least
would like to go to their caucus
i don't want to get in the way of that
so
unless anybody has any business to bring
before us at the moment
what about 131 do we is representative
woods ready on that one yet
well
tonight this is an adult and you can ask
me and i'm sure it'll give you a very
good answer
that's you know i said it's fine
would you
i'm not sure what you're asking me would
you like us to go forward would it take
about 15 minutes or would you like to
um
i i i'm not sure about 15 minutes there
the nature of the discussion may get
extended okay we'll give it the
attention it deserves okay
that in mind you've got the dates for
going forward and uh i will let you know
probably late this afternoon what we
will be doing um a week from monday
mr chair
jerry here
yes you may
mr chair yes i'm just i just we never
decided who would handle that amendment
on 605. the most logical person to do
that would be me i've already reached
out to mike holt and
started some preliminary conversation
about that so um i can manage that if
someone else has something they want to
put in or you know discuss it with me
obviously let me know but otherwise i'll
work on getting that put together well
since you are probably the most logical
person many of us know that is the most
logical thing for you to do
right i'll do it airmen point of order
one or more
uh mr chairman i just wanted to thank
you for giving us the numbers of who
signed in pro and who signed in khan
i'm the pest that was um requesting that
i just felt like on many occasions i've
told people that that's what they could
do to have their voices heard and then
i feel deep sense of guilt when
we don't know that what their voices
were so i appreciate you're starting to
do that i hope we can make that uh i
understand that those numbers are
often skewed by advocacy groups who are
very active but i still think
it's part of the democratic process and
i appreciate you um attempting to do
that well representative shapiro on one
condition is when i get ahead of steam
and forget to do it i would like you to
jump in and remind me please
i'll try to
oh anybody else can and to the question
of how many people have been signing up
from all over the place
i get uh printouts
with sometimes i get printouts with the
city and states the person is signing in
from on other occasions i just get phone
numbers with area codes which can be a
little tricky and so far most of the
people who have signed up
on all the things we've done today are
new hampshire people
not that other people don't have a point
of view but i get a little nervous when
there's a groundswell moving into new
hampshire from all over the place just
to try to tell us what to do
okay anybody else the hammer is ready to
fall mr chairman
well yes sir um the community report
what do they do
uh probably by sundown
tomorrow
i mean this this is grace purely because
it used to be you can't leave the ramen
i don't want to disrupt what's going on
in your house so
okay i see it
clearly yeah
just everybody when you're tucking
yourself into bed tonight just think
about the fact that i'm still up doing
all these reports
so
if i look blurry i'd tomorrow when i
come and i want to hug you because i've
never met you before um and i'll
restrain myself um at least make say
something like oh you look chipper
yes we will and thank you for doing it
um yeah or a hug or an elbow bump or
whatever something yeah
we're getting closer and closer now to
them
thank you
thank you bye good night everyone thank
you all and and a special thanks to the
clerk
yes
that is unbelievably important and never
thanked enough
absolutely thank you i'm just teasing
[Music]
just a reminder that they really want us
to lead because apparently in the past
we've been so funny that other people
want to transfer into this committee
that is causing the problem in the
speaker's office so good night everyone
yes
i won't be with you tomorrow i wish i
could be i'll tell you that but i'll be
give you some rewards for uh
so they didn't respect your shop
no they did not no they did not
um
well i'm still under a restriction i
cannot be physically present in a
meeting of more than 10 people even if
they're all masked and socially
distanced so that's a pretty high bar to
get to
when i am going to complete my
vaccinations
next tuesday the second
uh they come around to my to the
apartment to do it and
then 14 days after that which is the day
before st patrick's day
fish 16th i'll have finished i'm going
to go to the powers-that-be and see if
that's sufficient to get me to go in
person i'm hoping it will be
and if it isn't i may drink a little
more green beer on the 17th than i
i was hoping that they'd allow us
those of us that are really under some
strict guidelines to
attend in a separate room or something
but that all got washed away with
it i do think that i don't know if any
of you watched the proceedings but
our legal team really did a heck of a
job they spent hours and hours and hours
kind of put a case together and
they did a remarkable job but
you know
they knew it was a heavy lift because
trying to talk
the
courts into over telling the legislature
how to do its business is a very heavy
lift
well that's a shame candidate uh
your perspective is always welcome and
um you should be able to vote if you're
not happy with how that turned out no
it's i'm certainly not it's it's i
i wish i could do my job but what can
the interesting thing is apparently from
what the clerk told me
at the last session there were 44 people
absent
34 were democrats and 10 were
republicans now i don't know if the 10
republicans were not there for the same
reasons i wasn't there or if they were
just
ill or something like that i don't
really know but it's interesting that at
least it was a little more bipartisan
show up than i would have imagined